Hello freaks. I'm fucking multitasking
right now as I speak to you.
I am actually tweeting that
were live and a lot of people,
oh like dude, you can't do
that. And I'm like, dude, I can,
I'm fucking bad ass.
I don't like that.
I also turned the volume off on
my computer at the same time.
I give zero fucks.
I really do.
Boom tweet.
Dun Dun Dun.
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by
Squarespace.
Squarespace is having a contest.
That's why we're doing
two of them this week.
And what Squarespace is is the easiest,
simplest way to get a
really bad ass website.
And when I say a bad ass website,
I mean they look fucking completely
and totally professional.
It looks like you spent a
shitload of dollars doing it,
but in fact you did it yourself.
It's super easy to do.
And Squarespace is having a contest right
now to sort of accentuate that because
the feedback of Squarespace has been
so excellent and their contest is a,
we're going to pick,
we have the up to this week,
January 17th it ends and we're
going to pick four of the baddest,
most sweetest websites and for
the people that you have created,
those four baddest,
sweetest websites,
we're going to give them my free gear
of Squarespace and we're going to send
those winters a swag bag with items
like a Squarespace, apple keyboard,
t-shirt, mole skin, and more. What
do they have sound on their website?
How dare they fucking age of they
live in, in these freaks. Oh,
they put sound on my website when it
opens up so that it immediately starts
annoying. The shit out of
you is a video I was playing.
You know those old school websites,
you'd go to them and they immediately
start mind use to my space.
I remember there's like five different
songs going at the same time and glitter
tags. Don't forget glitter
tags work later. Tags.
What'd you just take a modafinil?
What that is?
No, you sure you don't want
to Xanax? No, no, no. This is
a, it's actually like speed.
Really? Yeah. It was just the opposite.
It's not really speed. It's, um, it's,
it's actually called Nuvigil
is what it is. That if I'm a,
if I'm tired and I want to fire him
my brain up, I can pop one of those.
And it's actually an experiment because
I tried something called sledging this
weekend and Jamie and I were actually
just talking about it. This guy, a doctor,
Mark Gordon was here and he
gave me these, uh, these, uh,
smart drugs and uh,
just we tried it.
We both tried a dose of it and a
interesting, interesting stuff.
So I'm comparing it to just feel more
lucid. I don't know. I'm not sure.
I'm not sure. You know, it's
hard. It's hard to tell.
Like what was my, the fact that
I got a good eight hour sleep.
What was the fact that they good food?
What was the why?
I think they're all sort,
they all play a part
of the thing to really find out,
you'd have to have a baseline where
you ate like the exact same foods,
did the exact same activities,
got the exact same amount of sleep.
You'd have to have that baseline
and then add in something.
But I take so many different nutrients,
vitamins and fucking nootropics and
all these different things without
prescriptions. And that's all legal
stuff. So most of it is nutrients.
Most of them, it's just vitamins,
keeping the brain sharp. Dominic,
you guys stay on the ball.
They think it's amazing, man.
Margic you already go on stage.
All of a sudden your mind clicks into
a different gear. Well, you know,
well first of all, you and I are
both eating Dick on stage four.
That's fucking terrible feeling.
So you're prep as a side.
Let me get through these commercial.
Okay, so we can just start podcasts. Uh,
anyway, go tweet, build the
website and tweet the website.
The Squarespace contest.
What are we talking about?
Squarespace. Your Fox. Pay Attention.
It's tweet it to Hashtag j r e
Squarespace before January 17th.
So go to squarespace.com enter in the
code word Joe and the number one which,
uh,
stands for where we are right now,
January and uh, and you can
save some money as well. The,
um, the thing that's beautiful
about Squarespace, if you
could do anything online,
like if you can,
if you can just normal shit like drag
and drop and click and if you know how to
select things, you could do
this. And the way that's, it's,
it's so easy and so intuitive that they
have it set up so that you don't even
have to enter in your credit card
information. Just go there and try it.
If you like it and you say this is
pretty bad ass, boom, then from there,
then you give them some money, but
until then you, you're not obligated.
Just go give it a shot.
Use the offer code Joe and the number one,
and that's Joe and the number one that's
for a free trial and 10% off your first
purchase@squarespace.com to do, do, do,
do, do Squarespace. Yeah.
Where's spaced on my is tagged.
Jrd Squarespace.
Squarespace. Do you think
you could do this? You,
you are not a real computer wizard. I'll
tell you that you're a genius comedian.
But as far as computers,
dessert, I would not,
I would not put you in
the wizard category.
I think you could build
a website on Squarespace.
We should have a context to see if dom
or Eric and bill the webspace on squares.
If we got you lick it up. You can figure
it out. If you had like a hot assistant,
you know, maybe a hot Japanese
assistant. Ms. Dot. Yeah.
None of them. None of them. When my,
when my computer comes on and
I go, yes, I did again, my man,
you're wrong baby. Uh, we're also
brought to you by ting. Ting is, uh,
one of the Squarespace and ting or two
of my favorite podcast sponsors because
they're both two podcast sponsors that
I haven't had a single person tell me
anything bad about. And then of course
someone listening to this right now.
I was like,
yeah,
Oh God.
Oh,
the first fuck tin can suck my Dick
in squares spaces filled with cons.
Fuck you,
Joe Rogan.
Um, ting is a great, is a great way to
save money and use a sprint backbone.
You don't have to worry about being on
some mom and pop cell phone network.
They use one of the biggest cell phone
networks in the country and they do it,
you know, it's weird. They're from Canada
and they don't, you know, they're like,
they don't operate in Canada. They
operate in the United States. I mean,
you could roam in Canada,
but they're a Canadian company that works
in the United States. Yeah. It's weird.
It's from Toronto. I, but yeah.
Um, I think, yeah. Um, anyway,
great guys and their
idea of great gals too.
I'm sure there's some awesome gals working
there. I don't want to be sexist. Um,
but their,
their ideas sell you awesome cell phone
service and do so in an ethical way.
A NO BS mobile service,
if you will. And um,
they have no contracts,
no early termination fees and they even
have an early termination fee relief
program. If you're paying an early
termination fee to come to ting,
they will give you up to $75 back.
They will credit you 25% of
your early termination fee,
which is up to $75 per device.
It's really a great company.
I really liked the idea behind this.
Sell you something that's really excellent
and do it in a way that doesn't make
you feel like you're getting fucked.
98% of all people who
switched to ting saved money.
I mean, I've had three very good friends
that have done it. Brian's done it.
Dr Chris Ryan did it and you know,
they rave about it, it's excellent.
And you really do save
money. Um, kinds of money.
The other guys charge you if you go over
your allocated minutes, texts and data.
But if you have a heavier month on Ting,
you just pay for what you used.
It's really simple.
So no mysterious items on your bill
and unlimited devices on one plan.
You can have as many devices as you want
on one plan, sharing, pooled minutes,
messages, megabytes, everything.
Each device on a plan costs a
flat $6 per month. They have,
it's really good deals.
And the phones they sell are all
the highest end android phones.
All the really cool ones. Like the
galaxy note three, which is what I have.
And Brian has the um, the galaxy s four,
which is an another excellent phone.
The HTC one is an excellent phone.
It used to be at one point in time that
iPhone was the king and everything else
just sucked. But it's very close now. And
then I fact I give the edge to android.
It's just because their
screens are bigger.
It's a way better experience if you're,
if I'm reading my text messages or
watching a video that someone sent me,
it's just a better experience
on that big screen. Sorry Paul.
I know you can't hearing this from me
and I know we were together for so long.
You know what I wanted is that new
flexible phone? Have you seen that?
It flexes the whole phone, but that's,
I believe it's just the screen, right?
I'm a screen. Isn't that what that
stuff's called? It's like a type of class.
That plastic you could
work out with the phone.
You could do a little in between the legs
like Suzanne Somers and get your thigh
master. Ron Her don't make fun of
her. She's a beautiful woman is hot.
It's hot as fuck.
Tink.
Go to tanning rogan.tank.com and uh,
you'll save $25 off your first
ting device when you sign up.
rogan.ting.com.
We Love Ting.
They're an awesome company.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible]
Dot com that's o. N. N. I. T.
They have a state on it program now,
which uh,
all the Onnit products you
love automatically delivered
to your door each month
at the lowest price guaranteed.
Um,
are ideas that people get annoyed with
having to over and over again by shit in
order. Shit, if you know what you like
and if you've used it consistently,
you can get it done and get it done this
way and not have to think about it as
much.
Would on an is is basically we try,
we call ourselves a human
optimization website.
And what we tried to sell you is all
shit that we think can benefit you,
whether it's health, whether
it's cognitive function,
strength and conditioning.
We sell battle ropes and kettle bells and
all things from making you the type of
man that dom I rera is. I mean, you're
not going to get there intellectually,
but if you could just, just become a
man through these, lose too much weight.
Looking at my face, I want you to
be brutally honest. You're not gone.
Your delicious. Thank you.
You look soft and lovable.
I just took a Calgon bath
before I came over. Smooth skin.
You actually still not a man who has
to work too hard outside in the cold,
frigid temperatures. I haven't done
anything since I started doing standup.
I never worked. I don't have a
tool and I went to, that's good.
That's a real comic.
That's why you're still flooding.
Uh, uh, where was I at?
Rogen on it, whatever.
Go get a battle rope wrapped around your
Dick. Stretch that pick out your week.
Fuck. Um, did just go there
and check it out on it.com.
O. N. N. I. T. A.
I can't even continue doing these type
of like super descriptive commercials
because the people that have heard
it a million times are freaking out.
But if you're interested,
go to on it.
Use the Codeword Rogan and save 10% off
any and all supplements. All right, dom.
Huh? Is he can't believe it. Got Him.
And he's super awesome
experience.
Joe Rogan podcast.
What's up baby? Everything's
good. Joe. You're a real
comedian. Dom Irrera you know,
you're just saying that for folks who
didn't listen to the commercial part,
you don't have a tool. You
know, you'd ever done a thing.
He never turned a wrench.
There's two bucks. There's
two, two bucks in my house.
And they were the lifts to women that live
with me. That having a broad tool box,
I can't even lift it is
when they can't lift.
I don't know how soap you lifted it.
That's hilarious.
Every time somebody shakes my hand,
they go mijo just soft hands. Oh,
the butter like butter. Smooth.
Yeah. That's, uh, that's,
I really do believe that there's a real,
there's a real factor in that you've
remaining on top of your game all these
years. It was like you surely you
truly like completely. You know,
you're a comedian. That's it. That's
what you're capable of. I love it.
I could do it in a hammock. I followed
crystal Lee and the other night at the,
he did a standing ovation and lift factor,
right? I walk in and this was true.
I had just woken up.
I took a nap like at nine o'clock at
night and the audience was standing.
I don't know. I said, first of all,
it's Chris just got a standing ovation.
I just woke up. I said, uh,
I was just in the bath tub,
like a big fat fag.
So Lazy.
The only reason I was taking a bath
cause to the stand up and shape, right?
And I said to the crowd,
and then what would you do if you were me?
What the fuck am I supposed to
do? Fly around the room, you know?
What do you mean after he,
after he,
after he had a standing ovation and am
I supposed to fly around the room and
said no, tell me what to do. They were
with me because it was honest, you know.
But the thing is what and what you were
saying about just I give a fuck. Totally,
but I don't give a fuck. Like I could
do it in a hammock at this point.
Let's just my head out doing stand.
That's actually not a bad idea.
That be pretty funny. For 30 a good
act. They were just laying there. Yeah.
Especially like if it was a
part of like a comedy festival.
Even a regular set. Ladies and
gentlemen, we present you dom.
I Rarer Anna Hammer and you just
swinging back and forth with a wireless
microphone in the air
and talking shit man.
Have things changed since
I started doing the show?
Redman is now taking x on
the road with him. Yeah.
Believe he took Tiffany Haddish, which
I said, you know Tiffany? Yeah, sure.
I said it's beautiful,
right?
But I said I would be afraid to fuck
Tiffany or even at him cause I just,
I'm intimidated by her and the Senseo.
You call that a Dick White boy.
I'll snap that motherfucker off. Have you
ever seen her queef until Michael Fun.
She closed it in Dallas and
it brought down the house.
People just couldn't
understand it was happening.
Like it was like a good ten second pause
where everyone's face. It was like,
wait that, that just happened,
that and then it just destroyed.
So she just put the microphone in her
box and she had been on stage for 30
minutes. I had a wet pussy. She's mostly,
she had a whip was even being on stage,
especially said turn yourself.
What's amazing that
honestly really the cheese,
the first one to think of sticking a
microphone in her pussy and [inaudible].
I don't remember it being done before.
I would have thought that someone
would have picked that up by now.
He's a cunt pioneer. Yeah. But
if you really think about it,
isn't it incredible
that it's 2014 for her?
What was it like 2012
when did she start queen?
She was on the podcast and the
icehouse chronicles like what?
Two years ago maybe.
Maybe it might've been either 12 2012
or 2013 either one of them either a year
or two a year and a half ago.
But she was, she was quite often,
and I was thinking then I was like,
I don't think anybody does this.
It's kind of amazing.
But you would've thought that somebody
would have locked that down. I mean,
that's been around for a long time.
The fact that no one's stuck a microphone.
Has any guy just committed to just
farting on stage all the time?
I mean as as one. Is this her
doing it? Okay, let's hear it.
Okay.
[inaudible]
hey
part of a fart too,
man.
I got tell you really
impressed pitches on stage.
If you see it close up,
tilt her back a little and you
could see her sucking air in.
So now you have to follow that.
Tony did, and he's sick right now.
He might've from the microphone,
I think. Oh Geez. Oh,
could you imagine if he really died?
You actually caught aids from microphone.
You're like, what the fuck man.
Not saying the Tiffany Haddish
I say that. All right. But yeah.
God Damn Man.
Okay.
She's a lot of fun though, man.
I'm so proud of her. She's,
she's on the Arsenio Hall now are trying
to build out after this episode. Well,
it is fascinating to me. I
mean it's just, first of all,
it's fascinating because it's,
even though you say a woman's onstage,
she could rapper sure. Vagina. She could
point to it. She could show it to you.
But when someone starts talking with it,
like you know that noise came from
that vagina that is several levels.
She's just have a levels more intimate.
Her Pussy,
he's talking to you.
There's Texas girls didn't know
how to act either. Their faces.
No one should know how to act.
Listen, no one on the planet.
We know that act is cause we're deviants.
We're deviants and we've been around
fucked up people our entire lives.
I mean you,
you've been around no one but fucked up
people since we started working together
and I've been around no one but fucked
up people for a decade before that.
So our, you know, our
perspective is a bit skewed.
The boyfriend drive to the thing telling
his girlfriend and the show maybe a
little.
Yeah.
Imagine if a girl was like,
really seriously Christian and I'll go
to the show because I think Brian rent
bands.
Cute.
But I heard that this girl
Tiffany Haddish Mike say tannic.
No,
Joe.
Do you remember the hooker
that we interviewed a long
time ago on the Joe Show?
Yeah. Yeah, in the parking
lot of the comedy store.
She was like telling us how she did the
business and stuff. I was really stoned.
I was like, I wonder if she's
still a hooker. And I found
her online still hooker.
Oh my God. Then what, like 10 years. She
didn't, she didn't get out of law school.
No.
Geez.
It's so weird how easy it was to
find her too. Yeah, it's, I'm torn.
I gotta be honest.
I'm torn on the whole idea of prostitution
because I feel like I always feel
like you should be able to do
whatever the fuck you want.
If you want to have sex
with someone for free,
you should be able to have sex with
someone for free. If a guy wants $1,000,
if you jerk him off and you're like,
all right,
then you should be able to do that. It
should be legal. That should be no more,
no more,
no more different than if you wanted
to get a massage like no one wants a
massage. You man, you're
paying them to massage you.
When you go to a spa and you
get a rub down for an hour,
that person does not want to do that.
You're giving them money and they're
making you feel good with their fingers,
like you should be able do whatever the
fuck you want and it's all our societal
standards that are fucked
up and weird about sex.
That said,
when I hear that someone's a hooker
like that and it's been a hooker for 10
years, that does not
feel good. It feels sad.
It feels like she's a lost and she's in
a bad place and I'm torn because I don't
know if that's my own bias perceptions.
Like maybe she's meeting a bunch of
people that are like really desperate for
touch and you know,
maybe she picks good clientele
and they have sex and she,
that's what she gets paid. And who gives
a fuck? Maybe it's not. Maybe it's that.
I mean, but instantly you say that she's
still a hooker. I'm like, but I'm like,
I'm questioning myself. I'm like, why? You
know, why does it always have to be bad?
Is it because we've associated sex
with something that you're naughty,
you're not supposed to do it.
So someone doing it for a living and
somehow or another a bad thing I used to
get after I fucked a regular
girl, like on the road. Why?
Just taking just cause it was wild.
There was the curiosity of it.
If I had one answer, Tj's left,
he seriously, I would get like,
I have like say like a waitress
or something on the road club.
Then she'd go and then they call
a prostitute, right? Total addict.
Oh, that's hilarious. Thank God
for blood pressure medications.
Do you think that's part of, that's just
being an Italian? Yeah, I really do.
Um,
you know,
there's always been that like ridiculous
stereotype of Italians is like
oversexed goons definitely is a reason
why that stereotype is and not for
Chinese guys. Okay. There's a reason
why that stereotype is not for,
you know,
fill in the blank.
It's like for oversexed a Pysch goons
for Italians is because they are like,
fuck shelfy for five years,
every day, every day, a couple,
at least a couple of times a day.
Even when she was reading,
I didn't need to know that, but
now that I do, I feel better.
Yeah. It's uh, it's uh, the,
my, all my ancestors, my
fucking, my family back home.
Like, although the Italians I knew and
that I grew up with, they were savages.
They would have grandmas,
they call him like they take the Gomar
out on a Friday night and then the white
powder on a Saturday. Did you see that
new movie? American hustle? I fell asleep.
I heard that movie sucks from so many
people. I don't know. I'm asleep.
I don't know. Do you like it? You gotta
Watch it again? I enjoyed that movie.
I have it at home. They sent it to
me so I sent it to me. It's like,
oh did he bragging about the stag thing?
They said what kind of a brag is that
if it gets bootlegged we know where it
came from cause dom I rare really knows.
Those knew I had to agree to a,
I had accepted the agreement like
they're going to trace it right.
Well there's a new thing they have now.
Somebody told me about online we
can get movies as they come out,
they cost 500 bucks and it's like you
have like a box in your house and that box
stores a certain amount of movies. Wow.
Yeah. Yeah. I'll send you the information.
I sent it to the guy who did the
ab in this place, my buddy and uh,
he said, yeah, it's legit. He said it's
a new thing. It sets up to your house.
You could store like x amount of movies.
You could have like 10 movies on it.
And they one time and they're all in
your name and they don't go anywhere.
They just plug it in this box and you
can play it on your TV and the each movie
cost like 500 bucks.
Wow. Which is weird man.
It's like Dan is a lot of fucking money.
But I was at the movie theater,
I went to see American hustle and this
couple behind us just kept talking and it
was a,
not very many people in the theater,
so they were talking pretty loud
because there was no one next to them.
And people just don't realize,
they probably don't even realize you're
being rude because they thought they
were far away. But you don't realize
how far your voice carry shit.
Nobody else is trying to,
yeah,
I was just going to say that I was
going to bring that up and it's really
frustrating. But you know, I just
dealt with it and watched the movie.
I didn't say anything,
but a guy got shot in Florida so a
retired cop had a gun on him and he was
texting. It wasn't even,
and he was texting,
texting in the theater and this cop wound
up getting in an altercation with them.
I mean that's step one and then step,
you know,
ultimate step 10 or whatever it is, is
he shot him. Who knows what happened.
The cop could have asked him and the
you could have gone, fuck you bitch.
Or of course has gotten crazy, you
know, 72 years old or something to,
well maybe he's just ready to
die on his own. And he was like,
start killing kids until one of them
gets me. That's why I like arc light.
Cause normally you could pick your seats,
but then if there's somebody
that's talking or something,
there's like a guy that just pretty
much stands in that movie. They,
they're on it like that.
Yeah, you're right.
There's another place called Sinny
apolis that's even more dope.
They have these giant lounge chairs fully
recross the recline, they sell food.
The food's really delicious and
it's a way better experience.
People don't fucking dog,
so it might be worth the
500 bucks is my point.
To have a new movies as they come out,
we might be worth,
what you do is you get the box and you
set up a camera in a dark room and you
film it and then when we make a DVD of
it and then we sell it to her friends for
$20 each and you get the $500 but you
want to go to jail and just retarded.
Which one is the,
that was my first line to him when I,
first time we did the show, it was
the way we met. What are you retarded?
I loved how you handled it.
It was beautiful. It is.
How do you handle it? You, oh, are
you handling it when you met him,
called him what it is? Well, I
think I was right, but I love him.
I don't know if I would pay
500 bucks for a movie though.
That seems like a lot of goddamn money.
That seems like at this point in time it's
like, come on, unless you really don't,
you know,
unless you're really annoyed by the
public and then have that much money,
it doesn't matter. But the problem is
the more you do shit like that, if you,
you know, you could become a hermit
man, you could be, we come a hermit.
If you really paid attention
to how goofy people are,
you get really at one point in time forced
yourself into the mountain somewhere
and just fucking be completely isolated.
You handle it well.
You handled it really well. You have
a lot of patients. It's not hard.
It's a bunch of people being nice to you.
But when we're shooting pool and
somebody wants to take a picture,
that's a little too much.
Well,
it gets annoying that that gets annoying
when you're in the middle of some
obvious activity. Or, um, when you're
eating, you're eating is a dumb one.
That's like, come on. I'm saying with
a mouthful to shake your hand too.
They want to shake your hand. They want
you to come. I've had a lady in, um,
Vegas asked me to come over towards,
I'm in the middle of eating.
I had a mouthful of food.
Hi, we're from Canada.
We would like it if you could come
over to our table. And I'm like, what?
Like I'm eating. No, I'm not going to get
away. Like how, why would you ask someone?
I couldn't imagine going up to someone
I didn't know and just ask them to come
over to our table.
We're big fans of fear factor.
I could come over to our table.
I remember when Bruce Willis for first
started getting famous Spec of the Improv
in the 80s and this guy comes up to me,
he starts shaking his hand and he wouldn't
let it go and just keep sending with
Bruce just looking at me and he goes, and
the guy goes, don it, get the, get the,
get the camera,
get the camera out of the car down.
Like he was holding them hostage.
So they took a picture.
That's when I first saw it at any,
anyone of my friends get that glimpse of
fame and the annoying part of it. Wow.
He just held onto and get the camera
and he's shaking bruises and Bruce was
looking at me like I'm supposed to do
it. Can't win. When he'd be pulled away,
you'd fucking punch him. Whether you
do, some people are definitely crazy.
Some people are just too excited to
meet someone like Bruce Willis too.
It's like, it's not natural. I don't
know what they think's going to happen.
It's kind of cool, like if you see
Bruce Wells, like Ooh, that's Bruce was,
that's a, you know, that's the guy from
moonlighting as the guy from die hard.
Yeah. That's Bruce Willis. He was
in fucking pulp fiction. Yeah.
I always tell people just enjoy their
work. Enjoy the work. Leave him alone.
Because if they met some people, they'd
be such a fucking disappointment to them.
Yeah. You know, mall. I
don't know man. It's just,
some people just aren't used to it.
In California,
I think way more people are used to see
famous people don't bother you here.
They don't say thank you. I like your
work til after the check has done.
So they're not trying to pump up the tip.
You know? There's a little bit of that,
I'm sure. Um, but California
doesn't give a fuck.
It's like if you're famous or not famous,
there's so many famous people here.
It's not that big of a deal.
But if you're a famous person like say
and you moved to Iowa or something like
that, that wasn't your be, oh, you know,
I know that just as a
comedian because in Columbus,
Ohio I get recognized more
than I can recognize that here.
But I might get recognized
but they don't give a fuck.
Well you have a big following.
You know,
it's Kinda interesting how comics develop
followings in one city or another.
And I'm never really quite understood
that. But you know how there's that issue,
like the, the best examples that
Guy Bob Marley, I love Bob Marley.
Great Guy, great salted, the
goofball sweetheart of a guy.
I've known him for 20 plus years.
Bob,
I knew Bob when Bob was an open mic or
in Maine who would come down and do a
Nick's comedy stop and he
would, uh, he did a guest set,
one of our shows on the
road cause he was like a,
the Bangor House comedian and this place.
But it's so real sweetheart
of a guy and a very funny guy.
But my point is that he's a huge
act in Maine. Yeah. Like people,
he sells books and albums and you might
have heard of them like most of you
know, fuel. If you're
a comedy fan, you know,
you might've heard them on
Sirius satellite radio or
seen him on comedy central
or something like that,
but he would have no idea.
Tell me a great story about Billy
crystal. They get into a, um, an elevator,
him and Chuck Bra,
Butch Bradley and Billy Crystal
was in Bible goes in and Brooklyn,
hey Billy will, you know, nice to meet
were comedians. And he just kind of went,
you know, like kind of ignored
him. And Bob says to me,
cause I didn't know whether the fuck can
push the stop button and beat the fuck
out or just let it go.
He said, so he let it go.
Wow. Billy crystal probably stopped being
a comedian somewhere along the line.
Well, you know what I mean about stop
being a comedian. Oh yeah. If that,
if you do that,
you stopped being a comedian.
Well he was always really nice to
me and then one time I interviewed,
I interviewed him and De Niro for this
comedy central thing and he was real smug
and shit.
Like he turned against me and I was like,
good scenario like is kind of
thick, you know. And I said to him,
cause he sang when mentally
like he's not real, he's not,
he's not there, you know, like real quick.
I mean he's a great actor, but uh, that's,
that's a whole different story.
But the Nero, I said to him,
cause he sang and analyze that and I said,
I love your singing. And I always look,
there's more than anything, I love your
singing obviously. I'm kidding. I go,
I says, you had the definitive Tevye in
fiddler on the roof and De Niro goes, oh,
thank you. It's all right.
Like you don't fucking get it.
He was barely paying attention
to and Billy was like,
that's exactly what it was.
I'm Billy was like, you know, kind of
snapping at me. I'm thinking, man, Bill,
you turn on me.
I'm another comedian just to go with it.
I think sometimes a guy like him,
we'll get tired of being the
center of attention, you know,
because I think also to be that kind
of an actor, he's not who deniro. Yeah.
To be that kind of an actor.
Don't you think he's lost some of his
legacy though by the doing these stupid
films? He's definitely has.
But I'll tell you what.
He was in American hustle and he's fucking
gangster in it. Yeah, he's bad ass.
I love the guy.
He's has very small part,
but it's vintage dinero but
that's my question. Like what?
When you work that much and you have
taxi driver and raging bull in your
itinerary, your resume, where are
you going to go from there? I mean,
he was just wants to work. So he's doing
the Fockers and all this stuff. Well,
maybe he enjoys
it. The thing, I mean, it's like he
obviously enjoys working, you know,
it's a lot of pressure to be so big that
you can't just do medium shit, you know?
Well, he put in some of the
greatest performances of
all time, the Cape Fear. Oh,
he's fucking Jesus Christ.
When he was in the empty
theater with the, the, yeah.
The girl when she be putting his finger,
his finger in her mouth,
that was fucking wild. It was
wild. It was a fucking crazy movie.
He was one of the scariest guys ever as
a medicine guy. And taxi drivers. Yeah.
Well, he always deteriorated.
Even in King of comedy,
he got crazier and crazier as the movie
went on. King of comedy. Oh my God.
If Rupert Pumpkin, you know what
I saw the other day, um, uh,
I'm going to have to sit down
and watch the whole thing,
but I was flipping through
the channels and it was on,
was it flipping through
channels or was I want whatever.
Somehow or another I was watching a
small piece of it, deer hunter. Oh yeah.
I was having a fucking God, damn,
that's a good movie. I got to stop it.
And I said,
you know,
I can't start it in the middle here and
just watch it from here. I'm going to,
I'm going to come back to this,
watch this as a full movie. I did.
That movie deserves to be
washed as a full movie,
just flipping through the
channels and catch that.
Not because this is sons of Italy
day, but the switch to one of the, no,
to put the switch to one of the
Italian Pachino in dog day afternoon.
You ever see that fantastic movie? I saw
it again last year. Fucking incredible.
Fantastic movie. But yeah.
What a weird plot too. Oh yeah.
There was just shrinks change
your story. Yeah. Yeah.
But it like the geneal
though. I mean, um, uh, uh,
John could says no. Uh, who's the,
it was that it was the Cino. No,
but she knows buddy who's pitching from,
he was famous phrase though. He, yeah,
exactly. Yeah. He played such
a weird freaky character.
And pachino was so on. It was like there
was, it was such a different person,
like this kind of guy who's robbing
a bank to pay for a sex change.
Yeah.
Normal seemed a little too together
to be that guy almost a little too.
They went outside. That was one of
Attica came from Attica. Attica.
That was a big movie, man. Yeah,
we can now he's reading about him because
they didn't want to cast him in the
Godfather. Michael Corleone, you know
who they wanted for it to Redford.
Really? Robert Redford.
Right. And then they,
then they watched and somehow the Coppola
one that him and he finally got him in.
And how great.
How great was he in that movie?
He was spectrum transition
between Michael and the Godfather.
I think those guys that do those
movies like the Chino and De Niro,
Harvey Keitel and all these
like historical actors. Um,
after a while it just fucking working,
you know,
so I can till the next really big project
comes up till something that comes up.
Don't die on us. Don't tell
us a little bronchitis, Joan.
I ain't no, not bragging.
I know.
Um,
but it's like to keep up
that level of work, you know,
to keep up the level of
work that they did like,
like Samuel Jackson and pulp fiction
to keep up that level of work. I mean,
that's like spectacular goddamn movie.
And how do you follow yourself?
And that part is so perfect.
[inaudible] that's one of the most
menacing parts ever. As another menacing,
like the, the menacing part of
a, of a [inaudible] Cape Fear.
Sam Jackson's Menisci part as a hit man
who's talking shit to you before she
asks you about your cheeseburger
that is d to tasty burger.
He was fucking horrifying,
man. I was [inaudible] about
the scene in true romance.
There's talking about the w who was
in the, uh, you're talking about,
we need to talk about Africa. Yeah. Yeah.
Gary Oldman is, are we talking about,
was it Gary Oldman? Christopher Walker
when he was talking about Sicilians. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Dennis.
Hi Walker and Dennis Hopper.
That was one of the heaviest fucking
scenes and but some comedy in it. Hmm.
Yeah. Same. A Jackson in pulp
fiction was a motherfucker dude.
When he would quote the Bible to
you before he would shoot you,
his wallet said bad motherfucker on it.
Jerry curls running around in a
suit shooting people. That was a,
that was a wild park. Yeah. He's a,
he's a good medicine motherfucker.
He's got crazy eyes and thanks for
doing my podcast anytime my brother
appreciate it. Can I do a shameless
plug? Yeah, sure. Do you mind?
Because he's fucking clubs. This shows so
big. Everybody asked me if I can do it,
if I can run 30 seconds. Is that
okay? What are you talking about?
Just mentioned where I'm going to be
stuff written down yet because they drive
me fucking crazy.
It's driving you crazy.
Any club that knows I'm going
to do this show. All right.
I'm doing side splitters and Tampa.
Can I do this? Yeah, go ahead.
Just does this in Tampa,
Knoxville and side splitters,
left factory Chicago Long Beach, Vegas,
funnybone, Columbus, Denver comedy works,
Stress Factory and Kilkenny Ireland.
This is all great, but this is Nike.
Let me tell you the best way in the
future. Just get a Twitter that you do.
You post on a regular basis and have all
your dates up on Twitter and then send
people to your Twitter or send people
to your calendar who you're talking to.
These people are not going to remember
all these things. That's the problem.
When you say a bunch of things in a row
that loses their meaning. If you say Tom,
I rera.net or.com,
boom,
the size following me on Twitter. How
much do you do a on Twitter? Do you,
do you get on Twitter all the time? Not
all the time, but I do it if I get drunk.
You know, there's some profound
ball, great way to promote Gig.
But yeah, your braid at that shit. Was it
all? Yeah. Do you do it before each week?
Taj got me into it. He
did it. He did a retweet.
I went from like four followers
to 10,000 because he retweeted me.
Read and read it. Yeah. Yeah. Touches.
Uh, he's, he's gigantic. Right.
And you know what's weird about
Twitter and like just being,
being around for awhile,
Justin Bieber has like 44 million,
something like that. And Paul
Mccartney has a million. Right.
And I know it's different worlds,
but isn't that incredible though?
It is kind of incredible.
It seems like a,
I mean I don't think Paul Mccartney
is tweeting all the time in the, yeah.
Does he use it? Cause Justin
Bieber actually uses, yeah. Yeah.
That's the big thing with one of those
guys. He's always in the laugh factory.
You know, he wants to do stand
up. What are you putting on? Oh,
it's just a story of a Bieber getting
his house raided this morning. Oh yeah.
Cocaine so far in it. And
they're looking forward to he,
cause he recently Egged his neighbors
house and caused over at 15 to $20,000
worth of damage, allegedly, allegedly.
But supposedly there's video allegedly
and I guess over $400. It's a, you know,
a felony. So they, uh,
they're raiding his home,
looking for any connections to that.
And you know,
if they find any drugs on the way,
they can just arrest him for anything
crazy as they need 10 cop cars to arrest
Justin Bieber. Oh Wow. They
took him in. Yeah. Yeah.
I think what the deal is is like if
recently in the news they've been just,
he's been just terrorizing his
neighborhood. He's been terrorizing.
They just got a posse with them,
you know, which is hilarious.
That would suck if you had
some multimillion dollar
house and you lived in this
really nice place and then you had
this crazy fuck living next door to you
driving down the street like 50 miles
per hour while your daughter's in this
draft, that would suck. You think
will end up killing himself. Well,
if he's doing the coke, it's
not a good sign. I ran IRA.
No, doing the coke is not,
not nobody just like
is really good at coke.
Like there's some people that are
good at surfing. Surfing's hard.
If I tried surfing, I'd fall flat
on my fucking face. I mean hell,
if you get good at surfing, you do it
for a while. You learn how to perfect it.
No one ever gets that way with coconut
in. He said to you a long time ago, Joe,
that uh, when you did pot, it changed
you and I think it really helped you.
I never said that about coke
when there was, you know,
Tony's doing a lot more coke lately.
Usually done his life together. Yeah.
A lot of people say that about meth guys
do math and all of a sudden they really
fucking straighten up.
Get the life in order to
pull your gums look good.
Well that's the problem with
labeling a drug is a drug, you know,
like saying it's a drug. If it seems like
they're all the same thing, you know,
they're the, what a drug is, is
something that affects your brain.
But the vast majority of them are good.
Like there's a lot of good drugs.
There's a lot of like a to drug.
I don't think it affects your
friends. A good drug to drug. I mean,
you might not like it, but
I like a fucking cup of
coffee. It's good. You know?
Uh, I liked the fact that,
uh, you know, there's,
there's drugs that could
help people that are sick.
There's drugs that can help people
that are in intense pain. There's drug,
there's a lot of drugs that have
like some real beneficial effects.
And then there's drugs
that will ruin your life.
There's drugs and nobody survives.
There's the, the opiates, the heroin,
the math, the, the speeds,
the ones where you hear about these
terrible stories of people's lives
completely fallen apart. You can, I mean,
you can kind of include pot in there.
I've heard people talk about other
people that ruin their life on pause,
but that's them inside.
That's just the,
they're looking for something
to ruin their life. I agree.
And I'd see that the same way as gambling.
You know, uh, the gambling thing.
People think that a compulsive gambling
is a very different than drug addiction.
I don't think it's different at
all. No, I think it's all the same.
Some somehow or another,
you get hooked on a drug.
Except this time you're getting
a drug from taking a risk.
I believe you can have that with sex. Oh
sure. With anything. It's masturbation.
This guys that have masturbated there,
Dick Ra and then like tried to
figure out other ways of jerking off.
I'm not looking at you in the eyes
cause it's you. I'm just saying.
Yeah. If everything we, it's weird isn't
it? That people get addicted to stuff.
The physical addictive part is really
weird that we like a chemical attaches
itself to our system and
then you need that chemical.
I guess what they say about Amy Winehouse.
They found no drugs in her system and
they think that she just quit drinking.
And if you are really serious alcoholic
and you just cut it off entirely,
you can actually die for it and go into
convulsions. Wow. I didn't know that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Amy Winehouse, when
she died, apparently it was just boobs,
you know, and everybody looks at her and
you think of her as this, uh, this mess.
You know,
this,
this awful drug addict boozer pill pop in,
but really,
you know, it was alcohol. Well, I love the
drink, you know, it's still drink a lot,
but I, uh, I would never wake up and
drink. Like that's, that's, I mean,
I'm not saying that's a good,
I'm not condoning light type of drink and,
but man, when you wake up and have
a couple of shots, that's a Tirtun,
you're not going to last long doing that.
That you're,
you're really putting
your liver into overdrive.
Amy Winehouse was talented as fuck
though. God Damn, she could sing.
She had such a sultry voice.
But do you ever hear about people not
talented because he, nobody cares. I mean,
it's like, look at all the
great people that died at 27,
like the people from the sixties Joplin
shampooing smarts and all three of them
died at 27. Yeah, 27 minutes.
That was a baby at 27.
And it was so stupid. Like it was play
basketball. I was in the comedian yet.
Well, I think we missed,
um, that generation that,
that Hendrix and Janice Joplin generation,
if you talk to anybody
that went through that,
they say that the change from the time
of their parents was so massive and it
was so much different than anything
that's cultured ever seen before.
It was a revolutionary change
and that was all fueled by drugs.
All of that.
That was marijuana and LSD specifically.
That's what was changed
and all those people,
and that's why they came up with that
sweeping psychedelic act in 1970 that made
everything illegal.
They didn't even have to have
like proof bioavailability.
Like they made some stuff illegal.
That doesn't even affect you.
It doesn't even work. It was legal. It
was legal before that, right? Yeah. Acid.
Mushrooms. I just used to get people
at Cary grant used to take acid.
Wow, that's heavy. Yeah. Well they
say, supposedly according to Mckenna,
the federal government, uh, originally
came up when they found out about acid,
they thought it was going
to be a truth serum.
They thought that they were going to be
ready to give it to the enemy, grab them,
hook them up with acid,
and then they would tell him all the
coordinates for the MTA enemy basis and
then they found out it was not a truth.
Here I'm, there's no fucking way.
This is the truth here.
If you ever take it. No.
So then they decided that it was going
to be something that they would give
their soldiers in case
they ever got caught.
You wouldn't tell the truth,
but could you fucking imagine
the there you're getting,
you're in war. Okay. You're some poor
kid. You've been shipped off to Germany,
you got a machine gun in your hand.
People are shooting at, you know,
bullets are whizzing overhead
and you get captured. Well,
how fucking terrified of you. You're
shitting your pants. You're going to die.
Oh my God, I'm getting captured by
the Nazis. And then you'd take acid
like was there ever worst advice ever?
I mean,
proof positive that the government is
not looking out for your best interests.
They give you fucking acid to take when
you get captured by enemy. Holy Fuck.
That's so ridiculous.
Well,
that was always like a paranoia of mine
is getting somebody to put something in.
My drink should be.
There's a lot of assholes out there.
I never leave but drink on the bar.
I never, you know, I always tell,
especially women don't,
don't trust anybody and listened to me
with somebody who loves you. You know,
I've talked to many people that believe
that they were drugged many people.
I think that there's a lot of guys out
there that do that on a regular basis.
It's one of the most disgusting things
about men is this thing that you keep
hearing about. I mean, I'm sure it
happens with women that women do it too,
whether to other women or whether the men,
but I hear about it with
men doing it to women a lot.
It's scary that someone
would be willing to do that.
That there's such a fucking sociopath
that d willing to drug someone who wants
to be with somebody who's just asleep. I
mean, I guess it's a different kind of,
they just wanted,
I think it's part of it is they know
they're doing something evil. Yeah.
I think part of it is they know they're
getting away with something and they
just want to do it. Cause it's
a crazy rush. Yeah. You know,
I was thinking about that with rape.
You know,
there was a woman who was raped
in the lower east side, uh,
like not of her body hang out with this
thing. I can't believe I went there.
That's not funny. Tom. Stop
laughs. Funny Joe. It's
horrible. It's quick. But anyway,
uh, I was thinking about like, how to fuck
these stay hard. I mean, it's gotta be,
uh,
just anger and violence because it can't
be sex or anything because I was like,
hey, how are you gonna stay hot when
you're hurting somebody? You know, there,
there's some people take their clothes
off and fucking, it's crazy. Yeah.
I think some people just have
a horrible view of humanity,
of themselves, of other people. You know,
that almost all comes down to,
if you're willing to do that to somebody
else like that, you don't love yourself.
You don't love yourself,
you haven't been treated with love.
It's really that simple, if you
will. If you want to hurt someone,
scare them and put terror in them,
and that somehow or another,
it gives you joy or gives you some
sort of a rush and you're willing to
sacrifice this person's safety and health.
You don't understand the connection
between human beings like you.
You've been raised in a terrible way.
Whatever's happened to you
along the way is a disaster.
It just shows you terrifying
aspect of society.
How differently can be programmed. Yeah.
You could react like that, you know?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
think about all the different variables
when it comes to creating a human being.
And you know, if you get
abused, that's the big one.
And people that have been abused and the
recidivism rate for people that were,
uh, raped themselves, you know, the,
the way that they turn to, uh, to
violence and violent sexuality, it's,
it's really, really common. You
know? And then the people that do it,
the people that abused kids are abused.
Anybody.
The real issue with the is
they don't seem to get better.
Like it's a weird thing.
Like they always have that desire.
They had this guy on a talk show once
and he was talking about it and it was,
he was a sex Predator and he
was a reform sex predator.
You did time and all that jazz and
it would just talk about how when the
thoughts come up he just fights,
fights them back. So he was reformed.
Cause a lot of them say that they can't
pay reform. Well he says he can't.
I mean he's controlling it.
Right.
But I mean the fact is he's also admitting
that he has these feelings all the
time. It's a fucked up thing.
Like what did it, what is that?
I mean we want to hate and we
want to judge and you know,
it is an awful,
awful aspect of humanity but just strictly
scientifically like what is that he
was molested most likely, right? Yeah.
Most likely unless there's something else
wrong and the development of the mind,
some blood got cut off to the wrong
area. I mean, I don't know, I'm guessing,
but fuck man, that's a
terrible combination. We,
we must figure out how to eliminate
that if you will eliminate it.
If you look at all the,
like the, you know,
look at the 180 degrees of possibilities
of people from really nice people too.
Really fucking evil people.
The really evil is a small number.
If you could just eliminate all the
really fucked up shit people do well on a
murder and rape. If you could
just take away murder and rape,
just those two murder, rape and robbery,
I can understand murder more than rape.
Well, I can understand it. Yeah.
And most especially, you know,
when you hear about how hot people get
just to know a row at a movie theater,
you know, guy shots got shoots,
a guy for texting, you know,
and whatever words were exchanged,
but yeah.
But if you could eliminate just that small
amount, boy would things be different?
Man, if you could just figure
out a way to not develop rapists,
not grow up murderers, not let you know,
if we just figured out how to do that.
Just those things that
none of us have done.
Just those things that most of our
friends haven't done. Just take those,
you know,
just those,
those are the rare occurrences and
eliminate them or drastically reduce them.
The whole world would be different.
Remember that comedian Vince something?
Vince champ or yeah, the one was the
rapist and he would go into colleges,
colleges,
but also the patterns seem to be,
he'd go into the music department where
it was sound proof the room and when the
girl be playing piano,
there's some practicing piano and that's,
that's what he would do. You
know, he had the whole thing
down. Oh No. Oh, that's us.
His name and Vince Chat. I think
it was Vince champ. I don't know.
I think that's the name because
a on the wall, the Austin club,
cap city, they used to have this Vince
champ joke. I forget what the joke,
really, very distasteful about.
Like when he got arrested for rape.
There's some joke about it.
Yeah, that's a lot. That's a lot.
That's a long way from a Dui.
Yeah.
Well it's also like a really
creepy thing at this guy doing,
he was doing it over and over again and
he was telling them to pray for him.
Oh really? Yeah. Yeah. He was,
he would rape these girls and tell them
to pray for him. Was that the right name?
Right ban? It looks like it. Yeah. Yeah.
That's my guy. Or Black Guy. Black, black.
Like there's all these reports saying
like, he was a nice guy. Everyone said
it's fairly religious. Fell out. Yeah.
And he's still in jail. Oh yeah.
He'll be in jail for a while.
Yeah. They keep me in jail for a long
time. When you're a serial rapist, I mean,
how long is he in jail? Right. That
down alone with my comedy club,
it's gotta be more than 25 years. Right.
Convicted of rape, kidnapping and robbery.
He stole two.
That wasn't enough.
And when not just talking jokes,
dumb.
He probably took like little pieces
of things from them or something.
That's oftentimes people
supposedly do that.
Take little pieces of something from
you but connects them like as a trophy.
Several rapes of the the music,
like playing the piano exam.
So awful.
19 year old,
he was convicted and given life sentences
for two assaults in Iowa with time
served for could be Harry,
he could be released in 2025
he'll be 64 years old. Cute.
How his life? 2025 how to do that. Yeah.
Life doesn't really mean life
anymore. It's like 30 years. His life.
Well they're too busy putting people in
jail for POCs so there's no fucking room.
Yeah, that's dear. What they're
doing with the people in Denver,
the not letting them use banks. I mean
weed is legal there. They're selling weed.
They made over a million dollars in the
first day and the government says you
can't put your money in the bank. Well,
what are you going to do? Exactly.
Wait, the people that are
selling the weed, exactly.
The people that are
owning these pot shops.
So this is the doctors or anything like,
like California. There's just no, no, no,
this is stores. This is
just, damn. Then? Well,
it's just like anything else.
It's in a store.
It's like selling tense or
fucking microphone arms, you know,
it's whatever he's selling a product.
But the fact that this is
available for sale and they,
they have licenses and they start
selling it and retail outlets, outlets.
But the government says you
can't put your money in the bank.
So they run into like some
serious danger because you're,
you're talking about
massive amounts of cash.
But they probably had a lot of cash
before it was legal. I don't think so.
Why would you think so?
I mean some people are just people that
took a chance and started a business.
Yeah.
But they didn't pay with credit cards
for when they sold pot of the streets.
I need dealers,
you know?
How do you know that they were dealers
before this house? I don't, this is the,
see this is now that it's legal in the
state. This is like a protected business.
It's a business.
I mean it's a real legal business.
They have a license to
do it and everything.
So it becomes a weird thing when you don't
let those people put the money in the
bank because you're creating
a really dangerous situation.
That doesn't make sense.
Yeah, it's really dangerous.
I never thought the eleague legality of
pod made sense and I don't even smoke
cause I have no agenda. It's just
such a stupid thing as such. I mean,
compared to anything else.
Well it shows you how the government is
not looking out for your best interest.
If they're willing to take these people
who are doing something that they voted
on and they deem lawful and take these
people and put them in a weird situation
where they can't put their money
in a bank, you're being a bully.
Like you're being a cunty shitty bully
and it's not, it doesn't make sense.
Like you're not protecting
anybody with this. This is,
this is actually putting people in danger.
So what do you do?
You're not going to arrest them.
You're going to agree to the state says
it's legal in states rights as you know,
as we all agreed on when they formed
this silly country states' rights as
opposed to take precedent,
it's supposed to be the number one thing
and then the federal government is only
in charge in times of crisis
and emergency in war and,
but you're supposed to be able to
vote on things like in, in your state.
The premise, it's like a little
spite move. It's a cut move.
It's a total cunt move. And it's not
just a cut move, it's, it's, it's,
it's nerve wracking. It's a, it's
like you're forcing these people to,
to stockpile money.
If they want to be in business,
they'd have to take bags
of money out of there.
Anybody could just rob them at any point
in time and you know it and they know
it. And so you put them in this situation
where they become targets and it's a
really sneaky way of being a cunt.
Well,
you would think that they would want
the money to become part of the system
because more money,
someone's resisting and they think somehow
or another as they lose ground over
and over and over again,
they're going to do this one thing
that's going to be good and get,
get him back to the victory column,
but it's not.
There's too much information now.
It's not going to work anymore.
He can't do it anymore.
You can't tell us that we can't do
something that's normal and natural.
There's nothing wrong with pod.
If you tell us we can't put money
in the bank because we sell pot,
then we tell you what fucking bank,
what are you talking about?
Who runs this bank? Why? How can you
decide what the fuck happens in this bank?
Is the government, the bank
connected? Like what's going on here?
How can you make this decision?
But who owns the money?
Right? You know, why can't,
why can't someone who's legally
making it put it in the bank?
What are you trying to pull here?
Well,
you're doing a business
move is what you're doing.
You're blocking someone out of business.
That's what you're doing.
What's known as they still got those.
They sell pot and shrubbery.
So there's there Megan, the
money. What do you do? How do you,
who dictates which money came from the
pilot? I mean you'll have to ever see it.
Oh, okay. Dot. Merera I counted
to one. Oh Lord is a whip Joe.
It's why, you know you can't deduct
everything if you deduct too much.
The government goes after you just in
spite and then they go after your ass.
They'll pick up your ass every four years.
So like I remember when before they had
the claim stuff and I was a valet in
Brooklyn, I w we wouldn't
make so much fucking money.
I had a suitcase full of full of ones.
It looked like I rubbed the dollar store.
It was the greatest then know.
Now waiters and waitresses
have to claim everything.
But that was a great world in the
eighties before the oil changed.
They came down hard on them. On tips.
Yeah. Do you ever work for tips?
Show you um, sort of,
I worked at a car wash.
You got paid in tips there. All
right. A couple of different places.
Driver kind of limo driver. Yeah. You
got tips as a limo driver, but you know,
it's not the big part. It
never had a waiter though. No,
I never worked as a waiter. I worked as
a cook a couple of places. Really? Yeah.
Or it does cook it.
A Papa Ginos and Massachusetts and
a place called Newport creamery.
That's gotta be fucking cheeseburgers
and Shit. That was a kid in high school.
It was good gig.
Everyone was fucking everybody.
Oh my God.
There was these hot girls that worked
at Newport creamery and me and a couple
other savages guys. And uh, it was,
we were all coming into puberty.
Everybody was like 16,
17, you know, we were all coming into,
I shouldn't even say puberty. We're,
we're becoming uh,
men,
young adults and men and
everybody was fucking, everybody.
There was like this constant hookup.
It was like all this gossip,
flip cheeseburgers, getting
laid dues. Great. It's all
bores. All high school kids.
It was a complete,
utter orgy.
Hell was this,
the girl who was the fucking worked
at the counter would blow you and,
and this and this guy was trying to bang
everybody and this guy didn't give a
fuck and this girl fuck these three guys
one night she got hammered and it was
craziness. We know there's a girl at the
lift factor. It really wants to fuck you.
You, yeah. And I told her, she lives like,
she's asking me last night, she knows
I talk about this in the air. No, no.
Everything's cool. I totally, you're
married and happy and loving family.
So I said leave him alone. Thank you.
Appreciate it. Well you got a damn wolves.
I think it'd be
way creepy.
Or if you were a chick though,
if you're a famous check that
a bunch of guys wanted to fuck,
that would be very unnerving.
That shit would be
Amy Schumer. Amy Schumer.
Yeah. All the comedian.
Yeah. We've seen a lot of
guys want to fuck her. Oh
yeah. Do you want to fuck her?
Is that what you're saying? Yeah, I
do. It's a weird time for confession.
I feel better now. Get it off my
mind. My mind. Where'd that come from?
All of a sudden you're talking about
Amy Schumer. Amy Schumer. What's that?
You have walk went off to Amy Schumer. No,
I don't do it. I know what I go off to.
Individuals groups.
Do you have like a wall?
Oh, female comedian. Oh,
Sarah Silver.
Blue Janeane.
Garofalo although I like
women. Oh, how dare you.
How dare you? She's a woman. She the
funniest. Let me tell you something.
I worked in Montreal for fucking years.
I'm one thing.
She has his balls and
she's a good actress,
but I have never seen anybody suck the
energy out of a room that you know how a
member of the club soda and she
is so fucking strong a woman,
but she's so fucking with people. She
was so bad that they didn't know what to.
I saw people like trying to think of
something funny that happened to them that
day, so maybe they could smile
and she died so badly and then I,
and she turns to me and it's like almost
in slow motion, like a twilight zone.
She goes down, did you give me the line?
I got to Janine, I don't kill the lights.
I'm pissed hosting the show. Whatever you
want. Do you want to come off? She goes,
no, I'll stay. I'll stay in fucking
die for three more minutes. Oh,
it was brutal.
Anyway,
well she's a person that,
she's very smart, obviously.
She's very opinionated.
She was a good radio host.
She was on that Air America show. She's
just snotty. Fuck. It's the very smart,
but she's smart in that,
in that intelligence,
you can sometimes be like really
caught up in it and take yourself super
seriously. And then when you do, a lot
of times you lose your sense of humor.
She was so rude to me.
I did mark Merrin's podcast and uh,
in Austin and she was on,
and she said they were talking about
some terrorist thing and I just,
I said, oh, that, you know, I named
the wrong guy. Right. I was just like,
not paying attention. Her and Norton
and people, she goes, is he serious?
It's easier. Like I wasn't
there. He's serious. I just
wanting to fucking throttle.
And I just was nice. And then when I
went on stage with her, I was flying.
That's a very Hollywood move of
what is he serious? Is he serious?
Well, you know, you interrupted, they're
really exciting. Talk About Obscure Shit,
right?
Or political shit or you know,
world leaders that they think
need to be addressed. Yeah.
People get angry if people are
not on the same page. You know,
I think it's funny when
I talked to someone,
they don't even know what the fuck
Twitter is. I think it's funny.
I don't get angry at them. I don't
care. Like she don't know Twitter,
like really what you
know is what you know.
I mean, look, I know a lot about sports.
You don't follow the NFL like I do,
but I would never be like, can appoint
Joe. How could you not know that?
The only thing I could
see it'd be annoying is
if you were interrupting.
If it was like it was like a really
important conversation for them and they
thought they were really
getting out a good point.
And you were crack at some chuck about
the wrong guy. No, I didn't do that.
I just was asking was that the guy?
And then that's when she said it was
the guy who was the president of Iran.
They were talking about people
take themselves really seriously.
But I've done that before.
I've taken myself too seriously before
or getting too caught up in an idea
before the point where, uh, you know,
think it's more important than
just being a person you have.
It's part of that Ismet which makes
you such a fucking hilarious comedian
because your point of view is
unobstructed eagle or once you believe in
something and that's it. And I like
that, just kind of commitment to it,
you know what I mean?
I mean,
when you like the things
about the universe and when
you get into certain things,
I don't know how much you really know,
but I feel it's almost like you're
preaching, but not in a bad way. Not In a,
not in a pedantic way, but just
in a way it's like, Holy Shit.
I think that's why he has so many fans.
Cause you felt fucking strong in your
beliefs. Some more people waiver then you.
Hmm. Um, maybe, I don't know, man.
When we talk about things like the
universe or just the realities of this
strange dimension that we exist and we
have that same thought about we are,
we've applied the same thought about
the Earth's orbit and we have no control
over it. Cause I told you that
[inaudible] thing that I have, right?
We'll walk onto the beach and be afraid
that would be sucked into the atmosphere.
And that's fucking where
it gets pretty crazy.
And like I'd be the first one since
the blessing mother that ascended into
heaven. You know, you're
just laying on the beach.
All of a sudden I'm fucking
shooting up into the sky. The Sky.
That's a weird fear. I
know. But I always worked.
I always carry anchors
with me to the beach.
We're so lucky that this is a time
where you could go onto just, you know,
space.com or any io nine.com there's a
million different websites that could
show you these crazy videos of the
universe and crazy new things every day.
I think this would be a shame to not
like take part in the wonder of that all
because it's all going on right now and
he's the revelations that these guys are
figuring out on a weekly, monthly and
yearly basis are fucking incredible.
They just took a photograph of a planet
and a star do something million light
years away. It's already burned out,
but we just got the light from it. Yeah.
Is that true? Yeah. And it's already,
it's already gone in reality,
but it took so long for the light to
get here. We just got, it hurts my brain
that it's my brain.
When you're looking at a star,
you're seeing a star that
may be already gone. Well,
the thing that fucks me up is that
there's no end to the universe.
Cause I'm used to doing in like the
end of the trail, the end of this,
the end of a relationship,
some kind of fucking and,
but there's no end to the immense
enormity of space that that blows me away.
Well, not only is there no way, I'm a
comedian, this is what they're saying now.
It doesn't make any sense to me,
but they could break. They believe
that the universe may be broken
down into individual sizes,
but then these individual universe is
exist in parallel with a bunch of other
like infinite number of
individual universities.
So what they think is that this is
impossible for me to even understand,
so I shouldn't even be relaying it.
But this is as how it's been explained
inside every black hole they think is the
portal to another universe inside
every galaxy as a black hole.
So when you look out,
you see 100 million galaxies,
what you're seeing is 100 million
universes and each side each, each galaxy,
if you go through the black
hole and the cough probably do,
and somewhere on that,
on those plants.
Imagine if Tiffany Haddish was the first
person at Queen for no microphone and
the university and the whole universe,
the whole.
If maybe that's what brings the
aliens here, we never thought of that.
We can do that. And we never
thought of that. Not into a mic.
At least this is truly groundbreaking,
this American art form of stand up comedy.
But the so what they're, what they're
saying is it's like, it's like a fractal.
A fractal is you ever seen like a
fractal image? No. A fractal images,
a geometric image that as you get closer
and closer and smaller and smaller and
closer and you realize that the same image
repeats itself over and over and over
again, infant in an infinitely. Um,
one of the more fascinating ones.
It's called the Mandelbrot set.
Google Mandelbrot set fractal,
um,
video cause there's a video
where they show how it works.
It's each, first of all, it
looks like a design. Like you
just look at it, you look,
it's like, okay, it's just some weird
design. It looks like, uh, like uh,
I dunno like a logo for a
cartoon or something like that.
Like just some weird design. But then
as you get closer and closer to this,
design it, it branches out all along.
The edges are not smooth around.
The edges are in fact the
exact same pattern of the,
of the Mandelbrot set,
the way it looks on the outside.
And then as you get closer and you see
it again and closer and you see it more,
it never ends. It's infinite.
Like what do you got there?
Mandelbrot set.
You see that thing to the right of it?
See the thing to the right black one.
That's the Mandelbrot set. No, no, no.
The one above it. The one
above that. The see that one?
The black one? Yeah, that's it. The
black one. That's the Mandelbrot set.
It's a,
fractals are fascinating man,
because they're able to create these
things with computers that you know,
didn't exist 50 years
ago and I'm actually,
I don't even know when
they invented fractals,
I think it might've been even
more recently than 50 years ago,
but the idea behind them all
is, um, that they're infinite.
That as you go deeper into the,
the macro, into the micro, you,
you see that this pattern repeats
itself over and over again.
This is the best way to describe it.
The fractal is a mathematical set that
typically display self similar patterns,
which means that they are
the same from near as far.
Often they have an irregular
or fractured appearance,
but not always.
Fractals may be exactly the same at every
scale or as illustrated in figure one.
They may be nearly the
same at different scales.
The definition of fractal goes
beyond self similarity anyway,
what they think is that
the universe is like this.
I think that inside every, every
black hole is a whole nother universe.
Not only is it infinite,
but it might even have its own laws and
made it have his own physical laws of
movement and weight and gravity and
light and all those things might be
different. It might be off, it might
be completely different existence,
and then inside those universes
are hundreds of billions
of galaxies and inside
them hundreds of billions
of infinite new universes.
Why always stick of that when they say,
you know,
we're searching for a place that
has water so that could have life,
but how do we know that there can't
be different kinds of lives that don't
depend on water? It's,
it all hurts my head.
It all hurts my head and that's
why I'm a comedian. Laser just,
it really does hurt my head when I,
when I start thinking about that each
galaxy would actually be infinite.
Like they'll say that even though maybe
the universe is 15 billion light years
across, it's still infinite
because even though it,
it's impossible to measure
a billion light years. Yeah.
15 billion light years.
Light travels at 186,000 miles
per second billion and 15 billion.
I mean that's the idea is that the big
bang occurred 14 something billion years
ago and from then on it's
just been this expansion,
the slow expansion to what we are today.
To what club are you working on this
week? I'm not working. I'll take it.
I'm going pig hunting. Are you
really the Callan? No, no, no.
The Steve Vernella.
We're not filming this.
We're just going to go shoot
some wild boars. Are you serious?
I'm totally serious. Wow. You've got
this whole ultra, that life man. The, um,
I'm very excited about this whole
hunting thing. I've become obsessed.
He said you should get a Gopro man. I
would really like to see like, you know,
you can get a GoPro that attaches to your
chest or your helmet or whatever rifle.
Yeah. The GoPro on the rifle would
be the way to go. Right? Yeah.
You see the bullet come out.
I wonder if you can do that.
Where did he go pick honey? They, they,
it was a ranch. We're going to a ranch.
They put the pigs out there. No, no, no,
no. They're wild. They're wild boars. Wow.
Yeah. They're uh, they're these
crazy looking monster animals.
Here are some of the wellbore. Yeah,
I've seen, I've seen them. Well,
wild boars are one of the few animals
that you can hunt all year round because
they have to keep the population in
the tone check if they don't keep the
population in check to the
results are disastrous.
Like perfect example is they opened up a
highway in Texas the night they open it
up. There was some insane
number, like 40 accidents,
car accidents where people
hitting base. Really? Yeah.
Because they're fucking everywhere.
Texas has an insane amount of pigs,
insane amount, and they're, they're really
out of control to the point where they,
uh,
they eradicate them through helicopters.
They have helicopters that fly over herds
and just gun them all down. Oh yeah.
It's crazy. Now, do you eat
them? Oh yeah. Oh, they're
delicious. They're really good.
They're really tasty. And
they're, you know, of course,
depending on what they're eating,
if you get pigs that are near people,
you're going to get pigs. You know,
they might be eating some garbage.
They might get ahold of some people,
but if you're having pigs that are living
out in the wild, there are sort of a,
they're omnivores, you know, they'll
eat some meat. They'll eat grass is,
they'll eat plants like vegetables.
They eat a lot of things,
but they're super lean and they're,
uh, they're fucking mean looking.
What does that,
uh, this is guy named Caleb that I met in
Austin and this is his dogs attacking a
wild boar that got on his farm.
I believe it was
okay. This, I don't want to see his men. I
don't want to see this gross. It's crazy.
There's a one way they hunt them,
man.
They use dogs and they sick dogs on
him and the dog's hold it in place.
Then they come along and cut the pigs
throat. When I say they not this,
this ranch, and they do that in Hawaii
a lot and they do that. And um, uh,
Texas a lot. They use a, these dogs,
the dogs hold the pig down and they stab
them. It's really kind of fucking crazy.
I think that a shooting an animal,
it's probably the most ethical way to,
I mean period of ending an animal's life.
If you're gonna eat meat,
even if you're buying
meat that's in a store,
you're dealing with the fact that that
animal was a fucking slave and animals
just sitting around waiting for its
death from the moment it was alive.
But if you get an animal in the wild,
like you're dealing with something,
then it's completely off the grid and
then you're stepping into its world for a
bit and taking something out of it and
eating that and that's going to be your
food.
Okay.
Yeah. With having the pigs are attacking
his property as dogs found him on his
product. The dogs were just like walking
around and then the pig attack the dogs.
Yeah, they'll kick your talks until
your dog will. They go after a person.
They'll kill people if you
have them in a pen. You know,
that's a real common thing with
pigs. By the way, these wild pigs,
according to Steve Vanilla, even wild
boars, it's essentially the same animal.
They can interbreed. They breed back
and forth to each other. You know,
there's different strains,
but they're essentially the same animal.
But if you have a,
you keep domestic pigs and you
fall in when you're feeding
them, good luck, Billy.
Yeah. They might eat you. They might
just bite the fucking shit out of you.
And once they bite you and they find
out that they can eat you, they're not,
they don't care about you.
They're going to keep eating.
You were going to hold you down and
fucking eat and no evidence. Yeah.
They'll eat everything and they'll eat.
They'll eat your got damn teeth. They'll,
you'd everything. They'll smash
everything up there. Fucking monsters.
Man and they taste delicious. Nothing
like Bacon. Well, in the F in the south,
they have a lot of the wild boars and
the domestic hogs. They like sort of uh,
uh, interbreeding and they're making
these giant fucking wild pigs.
Have you ever seen or heard of Hogzilla
okay, pull up the image of Hogzilla.
You won't even believe
this is a real animal.
They're having these pigs that are like
the size of cows, like a normal pig.
You know, they get pretty
big, you know, domestic pigs,
they get pretty huge. I mean,
I think they can get a
thousand pounds easily. Yeah.
But these fucking things are ridiculous.
Look at the size of that.
But that's a perspective one. There's
one where it's hanging upside down.
That's not the Hogzilla one either.
That's a different in different
large wild boar. That's it.
Holy Shit. Look at that. Okay.
That guy is standing right behind that
fucking thing. He's not too far away. See,
because his foot is parallel
to the paw of the pig.
So the argument that this
is like a perspective shot,
I think fades away because that guy is
touching that thing that's a big no zero
chance. You come across some of them
where you go, no, no, no, no. Those are,
that's like a deep south thing.
That's a Georgia thing. They've,
they've had that in uh,
I think fucking freaky man.
Georgia's where they've
gotten the biggest ones.
So that's a certain kind of
breeding. They breed them. Well, the,
the wild pigs and the
domestic pigs are breeding.
And then sometimes if they get out,
they can get really big. I mean,
who knows what could be. It
could be that, I'm just guessing,
but it could be that someone
fucked around with genetics.
Look at the size of that thing.
Jesus fucking Christ Dama rarer.
That is a huge, and telling me it's
fist to, oh, they're run, they run,
they run fast and they're muscular shit,
man. Oh, they're notoriously tough.
But the flesh is really leading the
way. Good for, you mentioned the old g,
the guy who got killed by a pig.
It's not the first people try not to live.
I wouldn't, I wouldn't think people
would be laughing. Dom, I don't,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
So someone lost her life.
I can't look at that thing.
They it to a pig.
Look at that fucking pig to tell me don't
think that pig would take you out the
pigs running after you Joe. I
don't think, I don't know that you,
if you knew it had a little bit nimble,
nimble him.
Well your tongue is very
into taking that Xanax.
Yeah, pigs are giant. They can get really
big, real aggressive and they have um,
what is this? It's just mixed in with
the pig photos. It makes no sense.
Um, anyway. Yeah. So pig hunting.
So he goes, I'm doing this weekend. Where
are you working? Uh, Tampa side splitters.
Sorry about the shameless plug. No
worries. An effective, I'll do it again.
People racing at a ranch.
Are you a camping? I'm doing,
I stayed at the hotel. Oh,
talking to Joe. Yeah. Yeah.
I just did a ranch.
She'd be fascinating.
Who you going with this guy?
Steve Rinella.
He's going to be on the podcast Friday.
Oh cool.
Does he is an expert on this
stuff. Yeah. He's a hunter.
He has a TV show called the meat
eater. That's a check it out. Yeah.
It's exciting stuff.
What's it on in Discovery?
No meat eaters on like
the sportsman's network.
I think you got so many
fucking networks do that.
You know they have a military network.
Yeah.
It's all just people get shooting shit.
What was the Hitler network? Well, that's
history. There's a, they called it.
It will hit. The history is
all like shitty reality shows.
I moonshiners it's been me and him.
The history channel,
they showed Hitler more than
anything. Do they really? Well,
every time I turn it on,
yeah.
History seems to be more like
reality shows now than anything.
They're all given up. It's almost like
you have to have reality shows on. Yeah.
She tried to put Nova on every night
and fucking science documentaries.
People just go click and asked whatever
they want to watch. Some rednecks. Yeah.
What's a duck dynasty? Yeah. Have
you seen moonshiners and is it good?
It's the dumbest one of all time.
But yeah,
it's the most fake domus one of all time
because cops are looking into the car,
like they're shooting this from the car.
The cops looking into the fucking car.
There's a television camera and the cop
doesn't bring it up. The cops like a,
so where are you off to?
What's going on?
He's looking into the car at the
fucking camera. He's not going,
what's the camera? What's going on?
What are you doing? No one says, well,
we're here shooting a TV
show that never comes up.
No one ever says we're shooting a TV show.
So these cops are lying.
Everyone's lying there.
All fakers they're just staring at,
what if they do another
tick? They probably do their
fucking selling moonshot.
That's illegal. If it was moonshine,
they would all be arrested.
There would be no show.
I mean,
what they're saying is that they have
these backyard stills, they make moonshot.
So I think now with the trying
to do is say that it's a,
it's all fiction and then everything has
been legal and nothing illegal and that
they're making, it's only water in those
stills and it's all just, you know,
but why do they even have wasn't
shine when alcohol's legal?
Because they want to make their own.
They don't want to have to put a
tax stamp on it. They want to beat,
be able to make it super potent.
Oh,
you should be able to make moonshine just
like you should be able to make beer.
You can make it absent.
Okay.
I think you can get absence and
certain um, certain, uh, dosages.
We were in Ireland and Mitch Hedberg said
to me, you know, he goes, there's Donald,
he says, I'm, I'm been sober all day. Go,
Oh good for you Mitch. And I love Lynch.
And he goes, yeah, cause I
want to do absent tonight. No,
look and see what it's like
from zero to a hundred.
So the only reason he was staying sober
was to see how fucked up he got on.
You know, like furniture, Polish,
basically his stuff for Polish,
it's like alcohol. Absence is like,
have you ever had it? Yeah. Yeah.
I've had it a couple of times. It's weird.
It's a too strong, it's a weird feeling.
It's a, it's like a cousin of drunk.
It's like drunks next door neighbor.
It's like you don't hallucinate.
They're all partying in the same party,
but there's a fence between them.
No, there's no hallucination.
It's just like being drunk.
Yeah.
It's just a weird drunk tastes way
or it's like black licorice ish.
Yeah. I'm not so sure. I like
it. What'd you did? You took
a shot or like a real, oh,
I had several. Yeah. No kidding. Yeah,
I had it a long time ago in Canada.
That was the first time I ever did it.
I never see you drunk. Yeah.
I'm pretty smart about that.
It's not a good thing to do though.
I really right with that beautiful car
you have. Well Dad, I don't do definitely,
but getting drunk period in public.
Yeah,
we should get drunk. Did you have
some night you want to get drunk?
Is that what you're saying?
I want to smoke. I told you.
Well let's do it. Well we should
do as book partners. Safe thing
drunk on the podcast and you
should smoke pot as well.
That'll be our next podcast. Sounds
good. Well we plan to it right now.
You've got two hours.
We don't even have a one 30 and dom I
rarer is not a man that likes to do things
impulsively.
It likes to plan things.
It looks to schedule.
Talking about you last night about what
a fucking animal you are like you're
just like so like he can't,
you shoot pool with Joe for an hour.
It's got to be three hours. Everything
he does. I said I feel bad for his wife.
She's got to be tough. I'm
obsessive. It's probably not healthy.
You got a lot of energy man. It's,
I don't see where it hurts you.
You got a great career with
the fuck. Great Life. Well yeah
I think I'm being obsessive though.
Could definitely hurt if it
gets out of control. Yeah.
It's just a matter of
channeling like obsessive,
obsessive thinking or the tendency to
like follow things down to the ground and
chase them down till they're dead.
But you've changed Joe,
like I told you, you like,
you know the thing about Michael
Jordan where they go, well he,
he didn't beat his mother
and Ping Pong and whatever.
He has to beat everybody and
everything and I think, well, you know,
there comes a point where he's
going to have, so you know,
and not that you were ever an
answer because you never wear it,
but you were so mad at yourself when we
used to shoot pool and stuff and you've
lightened up considerably. Well, I
realized somewhere along the line
way that that is a,
that's a very faulty way of thinking
and that that's all it is. Yeah.
It's like being upset because
you did something wrong.
Doesn't make the doing
something wrong better.
And just like outwardly expressing it
in fact is indulgent and they're really
intelligent thing to do is to accept the
fact that there's this shift in the way
you feel because you're upset that
something went wrong or whatever.
But you got to internalize that. And
that's part of being a man and being a,
a spoiled little boy or a,
a brash young cocky boy.
You people like fucking get mad and
throw things around when when they,
when they're upset, you know,
if they miss a shot, I mean,
I've seen guys in pool tournaments miss
a shot, snap their stick on the ground.
Well, yeah, I played with
this guy, Harland Jamieson,
the olds bananas and I don't know
if you've ever worked at club and in
Poughkeepsie. Yeah. Poughkeepsie.
And then that one, and he came back,
we'll be shooting pool and he was a
pretty good player and he would bang the
fucking stick when the claim I was, and
I go, Harland, if you keep doing this,
I'm out of here. This is like fucking
right. And he did nothing against me.
But it's just such ridiculous behavior.
It's not a man's behavior.
It's the child's behavior.
I mean, he never did that.
You would just get mad at yourself.
Yeah, well I would just, I would be,
I would know it was always a
lack of concentration. I mean,
she just shots that you miss where you
know, you just didn't hit it right.
But there's also shots you miss where,
you know, it was a fairly makeable shot,
but you took it for granted and
you're like fucking idiot. You know,
those are angry ones.
It wasn't Mrs. It was more of lapses of
concentration that I was really upset at
myself for. But yeah, the shit doesn't
do you any good. No. Now laceless energy.
Yeah. Now I just internalized or a
try very hard to just internalize,
but that's um, that's just a factor
of getting older and smarter. Yeah.
You hope doesn't happen everybody.
Huh? I know that's the saddest thing.
When you find dudes that you didn't talk
to in a long time and they've regressed,
they become more delusional
or more complaining. You know,
a lot of guys are complaining, talk to
me. I'm talking to him in a long time.
We talked to him in this,
this overwhelming coming.
Oh yeah, no, I hear that all the time.
I've got a friend who does cruise ships,
you know, and he doesn't like it. He's
got a family and he does other stuff too,
but he's always fucking wine.
He says, listen man, you're
making me. I said, look,
you see this thing? She just
car. You see this, you will boy.
It was all bought through jokes.
You know how fucking hard
some people work for nothing.
They can't get shit jobs and I'm supposed
to feel bad for you because you're
going to Turkey. You know that's a hard
gig though. Oh, I wouldn't want to do it.
The cruise ship said currently.
So you're right though.
It's definitely better than coal mining.
Oh yeah.
A lot of people would be super happy
to do it. I love when people go. What?
You did the hardest thing
in the world? No, I don't.
But at the guy who discovered these,
what were just talking about,
what were the mirror things?
They, fractals. Fractals.
Yeah, I'm fucked us that.
What kind of mine. Yeah. Super Smart
Science students and no one wants to fuck.
That's what's up. Yeah, exactly.
When they get more time on her hands,
once they start getting pussy throb,
they're fucking signs deteriorates
drastically. You know,
this is all like you have
to have no chance that pussy
to be sitting in front of
a computer banging this out cause there's
just some girls out there that would
just rob you of all ambition.
Whenever I think of uh, no chance of
the, I always think of that bit. You had,
you know, the one that, the new
rules, but I always think of the guys.
What was the guy's name? Who she married?
He was in his nine j Howard Marshall.
Marshall. No chance of pussy
unless you're a trillionaire.
Uh, 1904. Actually it was
when fractals were invented.
I was way off. That's
fascinating. That's the,
the earliest modifications.
Yeah.
Who the fuck are those guys though?
I mean you think about like the
things that we use on a daily basis,
like computers, all the things we need.
I have no idea how any of that works.
Not only do we not understand
how it works, but even if we did,
even if we knew exactly how
the operating system works,
exactly how the memory is stored,
which you could never make that thing,
you can never build anything,
never invented on your own. I can't
make anything. Yeah. But I mean,
I'm not even you. I mean, any of us,
it's fascinating how much of our society
relies on things that almost no one
understands.
I don't fucking understand plumbing.
I don't understand how you can get the
same water pressure on the 10th floor as
you have on a second floor. It's crazy.
It's madness. That's must be a river on a,
down the roof. Yeah.
Water pressure. Weird.
Uh, you ever have, um, uh, like
a, a route get into your pipes?
No. Never had that happen. I had a route,
got into my pipes and grew a
fucking tree. All this shit. I mean,
when I tell you grew up here right now.
Yes. Oh Man. Yes. When I went to Colorado,
when I was gone for awhile. The
uh, when you flush the water,
the uh,
apparently like there was these little
tiny cracks in the pipe from the toilet,
uh, down to the street. That's
it. See that thing right there,
that was a inside my toilet growing.
It looks like a Muskrat, right? Yes.
That is, that is a fucking route. Oh
my God. That's the root of a tree.
So it got through and then because
it was all that water in there,
it started growing like crazy and,
and was searching it cause
that's what routes do they,
they grow down towards where
the water isn't, suck it out.
That's how they get
moisture out of the ground.
So it cracked my pipe open and
grew inside of it. That's real.
That's not made up that image. I mean
if you, if you're listening to this,
it looks almost like an animal. Well
how do you find that? What's the,
is it on a flicker Joe Rogan route pipe?
Just like I didn't get blend tech right
there. Just Google Joe Rogan route pipe.
Yeah.
I wouldn't do that because it's filled
with poop that was fed by poop and peep
and water and that thing grew like a like,
hey, we'd like a veritable read dumb.
Yeah. I don't understand it either.
I've got a new thing recently, um,
that it's instant hot water. You know
the talk there. Tankless water systems.
So your water goes through this thing
and it instantly turns hot. It doesn't,
you don't have a tank of water
just sitting around getting hot.
That would be good for my sitz baths.
What's amazing is it like safe?
You never run out of hot water. That's one
thing that's cool. Like you know. Yeah,
just got it. So like if someone's using
the water and like if you're young,
you have a friend that
takes a long shower,
well you go in after that
person and you're fucked.
You know you're going to have to take a
mediocre ass shower cause there's no hot
water left with these things.
Now they have it so the water can
go through it and it's always hot.
People will be coming over to your house
to take beds. That's, that's my plan.
And my friend that's a,
you get them naked.
So it's in one place in the house or
is it like on every single like faucet
there's like, oh no, no, no.
It's in one place. It's one,
one area where the water comes in and
then it regulates it out from that. Oh,
it's ridiculous.
It's one of the weirdest things ever.
It's just like how the weight, what
happens? Huh? So the water ends.
I mean it's hot as fuck too. It's not
like it's kind of hot. It's Kinda hot. No,
it's, it's boiling hot all the time
right out of the gate. So it's weird.
I don't know how the fuck did they get
their plumbers put that in or is that
like a specialty regular plumbers? Yeah,
it's, it's something they put in now.
It's normal thing. And
you know, a lot of people,
especially where we live are going full
solar because you can go full solar
where you don't even have to be attached
to the grid. There's enough sunshine,
southern California. We could just
have these pretty cool, it's crazy.
I had a guy come over last week, my
garbage disposal is down. And uh,
he recognized me, right.
And, uh, now we recognize me.
He also gave me coupons.
I'm thinking,
I guess he recognized me but doesn't think
I'm doing too well. And then he said,
I got to tell you it's
a pleasure to meet him.
Mr O'hare o Herro Hara Hara
and my name is written on it.
I rarer, he just didn't look to, while
he's just not good at pronouncing things.
Amy, I rera Save Shit. He
could be a little black Irish.
I had a woman call me mister Irene.
Talk about lazy.
I'll be up there in the second. Mr
Irene Room Service. She made a mistake.
Don't get upset. Don't get upset. I like
it. And you just turned it into bits.
Joe turned into comedy
gems and do you ever, oh,
come on. What about you? Don't
start with me and do you ever, um,
and I saw you at the ice house. Yeah.
Fucking Billy crystal. That's right.
We just said it. Fuck Chris. Talk
about throwing that in your memory,
but it can splurting it out an hour later.
Bobcat,
Bob Marley's the nicest guy in the world.
Oh Man.
Crystal giving him the cold shoulder.
How dare you Billy.
I know it'd be only knew
mustad sounds a little smug.
I gotta say that's unfortunate. Yeah.
And he's had a beautiful career, man.
He's fucking smug. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, you know it's fucking,
it's a lot of pressure.
A lot of pressure on those guys.
A lot of times they crack fuck them.
They start buying it in their own
polo shirt. Yeah. I think that's a,
the guys who don't are the guys who keep
doing standup because no matter what,
no matter how fun you are
of how famous you are,
or rather when you get on that stage,
you have to be fine.
They give you a couple of minutes.
But you gotta be funny, Joe.
I haven't been on stage since the Friday
before last the longest in probably 20
years because of being sick.
Yeah. Wow. But isn't that true?
Like that's how we do it.
Like a lot of people folks don't know,
like they've never ate five nights a
week off or two months out or something
like that. It feels really
weird. But you come back,
it can't be a wiseguy crack wise cracking
Italian community and what a hacking
cough. It doesn't work, you know? And
that's, that's why I couldn't go on.
I mean that could have made it,
I've been on the stage with
fevers and torn muscles and shit,
but the cough would be fucking did me in,
I only had to cancel one gig ever.
Wow. Um, as far as like a
weekend, it was a, I think maybe,
maybe when I was younger I did,
but that I could remember like as a like
a Gig that was supposed to fly out to,
I took, I think I was supposed
to do it. Stress Factory.
I'm pretty sure that was what it was.
Like any brand. I got the fever flu. Ooh.
It was bad.
It was,
it was one of those ones where it was
like on Monday I cancelled. I was like,
there is no way. At least he
gave them that. Yeah. It was bad.
They'll fucking few flu that's going
around right now as a mother. Fuck Dude.
I've talked to some people that got it
that like we're fine and then two days
later they're in the hospital
on Ivy. Really? Yeah. Holy Shit.
They're showing in Houston
that people were like,
I think they were up to like 50
people have died from the flu.
I'm sure it's old people and babies, but
uh, well you know, if you fuck up man,
that's the thing about
like being sick or um, not,
not, not having a healthy
body, a healthy immune system.
Like when you're not healthy all the time,
like he's pulling all nighters,
getting a couple of hours
sleep before you get to work.
You're working all day and drinking
coffee and your immune system is fucking
getting chipped away.
If that is when it enters into your life,
like you can die,
you can die if you,
if you're hung over and drawn
out and fucked up and then boom,
you get hit with the flu.
Holy Shit. You can get jacked.
I had so many people like
bummed me out first day,
like act like they care and they
know. Oh yeah. You know? As I said,
I think I'm getting better. Yeah. He
goes, yeah. A friend of mine had done,
you know lists like three months
or so. Thanks. You know, it's good.
Thanks for cheering me up.
Just telling me his friends opposed to,
that's what I would say. Fuck him
friends. Your friends are posting.
I'm we be back in two days
a smack them three months.
The fuck out of here.
I'm going to call it last three months.
It's not a goal anymore.
Yeah, it's an epic Tequila.
Asthma does what you have now.
Do you have asthma? I got
something. This thing is this,
this goes so I got to inhale it.
You know what's good for asthma?
Pussy stank up was a that too,
but a wade and my friend made it once
and I wish I could smoke right now,
but I just don't know what would happen.
I've got to drive that panic. Yeah. Yeah.
He'd go into a tailspin. We'd have
to be like slid out of the corner.
Are you allowed to do
that with Xanax though?
How does that work if you taken Xanax?
I don't know cause I never,
I mean Xanax is a tranquilizer.
Oh you might stop breathing.
Xanax feels like Xanex feels like what
you would think normal people feel like.
No, it's not a high, it's just, I mean
I never take it enough to get high,
but it's just like a relaxing,
you know,
just do some indicates what's a cause
the downer that we'd like, you know,
there's an Oh is it? I'm sorry.
There was a article that said that.
That's bullshit. I thought that was
really interesting. I know it's always,
it's pretty established know
some article that said that. Uh,
I don't know whether they're saying that
the people that are selling are full of
shit, but they were saying that you, the,
the two different highs are
indistinguishable. And I was like, man,
I don't know about all
that bullshit article.
Well it seems like you're not
getting high enough to really,
you'd have to do it and get out.
It's like a,
Somalia can tell the difference
between Lowe's and cabernets.
Like right off the bat. Right.
They can just tell. I can't tell.
I don't know what the
fuck the differences.
I had no idea there was
a pot that was a downer.
Well that's what most people think of
as for pot. They think of, Oh Gee Kush.
They think of like we just chill dog.
It really just makes you just really not
give a fuck just kicking back and just
your eyelids get heavy and
then this pot for me at least,
that makes me like really think about
shit and really get introspective and
breakdown my life and life itself.
The city and universes
and shit like that. That's that to
me, whatever it is, whether it's uh,
the different cannabinoids
are the different strain or
whatever the fucking has.
There's a different response. I have
two different kinds of weed. I thought.
I Dunno, I don't, I mean maybe
a, maybe I'm wrong about it.
Maybe I'm wrong about the, uh, the
way the, the mechanism is working.
I just know when I get good stuff.
Well what fuck me up was,
I had no idea that it took a
while to hit you. Xanax, no pot.
So when I first smoked,
this is why I had such a bad experience.
I just kept smoking joint
after joint, like, you know,
in in a half an hour I smoked like,
I dunno, three or four joints.
There's just like, oh my God, these
guys are going, Holy Shit. Look at him.
And I'm thinking,
and I did this with southern comfort
once and I almost died from alcohol
poisoning because I just kissing.
I was like, I just liked, you know,
it's like getting the crowd behind
him. Where were you? The Pot? Yeah,
I was at the University of Pennsylvania.
Uh,
I got an apartment down there and Philly
and just with a bunch of guys fucking
around who's pot wasn't, I dunno,
it wasn't mine. And you know,
so somebody else brought the pot and
then you just started smoking up a storm.
But I had never smoked.
And the,
and then it just kept smoking and this
was like really like a lot of smoke,
you know? I don't know. Even like, and
that's why I think I got so fucked up.
Of course it everything like the Breck I
was why this was when there were albums
now and everywhere.
I remember watching the record revolved
and just getting lost in that, you know,
what was the song that was
playing? It was um, tomorrow,
never knows it was a Beatles
song and turning off your mind,
relax and float down the stream,
you know, that's all it is,
not dying or whatever.
And um,
and that was real psychedelic kind of
song. Anyway, I was like, ah, fuck.
I thought maybe my head felt smaller,
you know, just everything was weird.
That's why I had a bad experience.
That's what I want to try it again.
And so did you get paranoid?
Yeah, very, very bright orange.
And what bike do you remember
specifically what you thought about?
Just that the whole world looked different
to me and see the only time I was
ever, I had gotten fucked up on
cough medicine in high school.
Did you ever do that?
I did cough medicine when I was an adult.
I took Nyquil once when I was sick and
it was one of the happiest days of my
life.
So this was like,
I drank a whole bottle of
Romel RCF I swear to God.
I mean, I, that was, I
think that's why, uh,
up any kind of upper drugs have had
negative effects on me because of that.
And then I did the pot and so
that's why I never did them.
And everyone's against drug. Well,
that seems like a very likely scenario.
If you smoke that much pot the
first time he did it, that is,
you're going to freak the fuck out.
That's, that's, well, nobody told me,
nobody told me they were going wow, look
at him. And I was like, Oh yeah, look,
one hint. Yeah, that's all
you need. Just one. She,
that's not even a big one. Not even
a big one, just to tiny one. Just to,
to really feel what pot does.
You want a tiny amount of it.
That way you distinguish
it from regular consciousness. He fuck
around with it, get a feel for it.
See the, the, the good and the bad about
it. And occasionally going to push it.
Occasionally going to get too small.
You're Gunsmoke two hits and three hits.
They ain't going to feel weird
as fuck and you gotta go,
you know me better back this down.
So we back this down,
take it down to one again, bring it
down to one and just try one for awhile.
But when people start smoking a
whole joint or two g your code,
that's like he had never
ridden a motorcycle before
and you get on one of those
Ninja, you know, just go ahead
and done it. You know what?
You can't do it. But those guys
who do it every day can do it.
It's a similar thing in a way because
it's the experience of being really,
really high is manageable. Say if
you're a guy like Everlast, you know,
if you get high all the time and
you're just naturally cool, dude,
that can deal with shit. But if you're
a guy who's never gotten high before,
like that can fucking be marble.
Terrifying.
It was terrifying. What were you
thinking about when you said the world?
It just didn't look the same. Uh, just
the proportions of things look different,
you know,
like as if I was zipping,
my eyes were different lenses that
they changed, you know, for a while.
And you know,
I was just getting a thought in my
head that like giving them the song.
W We keep playing in my head when it was
over. You know why it was pretty heavy.
I mean, I guess it was close
to a trip, you know? Wow. Yeah,
that sounds like what I go through
every night. Like a typical day.
I went through the end of the
tank last night. He went to what?
I went through that in the tank. Could
you do the tank? Yeah. Yeah. I've Joe,
you're unbelievable.
You're so funny.
You got so many fucking varied interest
in all. I watch sports center lists. No,
that's what I did. But that's,
we're all different. Dot.
Merera I'm just trying to maintain and
not go off the rails into crazy town.
So what do I do? I hunt bores
and aligned saltwater. Typical.
I'd throw kettle bells around
just trying to keep it together.
You got to fight this week?
No, this week is no UFC.
This week I said I'm going for hunting.
The next UFC is not until the week
after that and Chicago, I'll tell you.
Thanks again for the Montreal tree.
Did you enjoy it more than enjoy the
Tammy pass could tell you another would
have fucking,
I mean that guy like the excitement.
I could just imagine like it's like
the gladiators, the Roman Empire.
Like the excitement in that room when
the French Canadian guy walked in.
George Saint Pierre. Yeah. Oh my God.
And then the fight itself and it was,
it was great. Yeah. Those live events or
there's something special like seeing,
seeing the UFC live is this
very few things that have
as much electricity in the
air. So much potential drama and
while the fights are going on,
there's so exciting. It's so
exciting. And I, you know, you,
you invited me to a couple of them and
I was so amazed at how clear I see the
crowd is. It ain't like professional
wrestling crowd skate on his face.
I mean, they're like really nice
people. They look, but they're not well,
I always hoped that it would go closer
and closer towards the ethics of martial
arts because I think that if you
looked at the best guys ever,
the best UFC fighters are martial artists
from hoists. Gracie, the original,
you know,
to look at like Leo Machida or Anderson
Silva or George Saint Pierre Silver
broke his leg. Anderson brogues
lag. Yeah. The last fight.
These guys are martial artists like
the Anderson bows for every match.
Liotta Machida bows,
George bows like they are,
they're literally upholding the
original codes of martial arts conduct.
I mean, they are martial artists
and those are the best guides.
It's not these brawler fuck you spit
in your face kicking the balls, guys.
Those guys are not the,
the, the champions.
The champions adhere to this sort
of philosophy and principle of,
of excellence that I think,
yeah, it kind of have to have,
and the people that are attracted to that,
there's going to be a bunch of
knuckleheads in the audience. I mean,
it's unavoidable.
You get 18,000 people,
you're going to get a few
dozen crazy people for sure.
There's no way around in
any game baseball, you know?
But overall I think that what the fighters
project that they project a level of
respect and a level of
discipline and dignity that a,
the audience, they, I think they take
that in. I think they appreciate it.
Whereas when you're watching the WWE,
you'd know that it's scripted.
It's a wild, crazy event and it's fun and
it's entertaining and it's acrobatics.
And you know, those guys like they
were in the rock is a serious athlete.
Brock Lesner,
he's a serious athlete.
Brock Lesnar was pretty successful in
the UFC for a guy that didn't have any of
MMA fights to speak of
other than one before.
He entered into the biggest stage
on earth as a fighter. I mean,
he's a ballsy motherfucker,
you know?
So no disrespect to the
wrestlers or anything like that,
but one of the reasons why the
audience will act like that,
it's because they could feel it.
It's not real. It's all horse shit.
They're just there. They're like trying
to suck excitement out of, out of the air.
But don't you think there's certain people
that believe it's real no matter what
you tell them?
100%.
I talked to a guy from a Abu Dhabi who
was telling me that his friend absolutely
believes that it's real and he
cannot argue with him about this.
Not so frustrated.
He didn't know what to say.
My doctor thinks all professional
football is rigged. Really? I go,
how the fuck can they get to all these
guys? This is, I'm listening. He goes,
you're going to tell me that, you know,
Brady couldn't throw a pass. And I go,
I don't know. But how do they get to
the center? How did they get, you know,
it's the company becomes a
point where it's just paranoia.
Some people don't like the wool
pulled out over them, you know,
pulled over their eyes. So they, uh, they
like to look for it and everything. Uh,
these motherfuckers are all in together.
Yeah. Right after you fcs all the time.
I'll get tweets like, yeah, you
know, it's a fuckin fixed fight.
That was a bullshit. Fuck that flex fixed
and you know it. Oh, fights can be fixed.
I mean,
they certainly can.
Fights can be fixed basketball games
with ribs or a guy who missed his foul
shots at the, you know, but
when you get to a whole fucking football
team, it's 22 guys plus Reps. I mean,
come on. Well, the thing
about basketball is you, uh,
I mean they have absolutely proven that
referees have been involved. Oh yeah.
They've, they've, they've proven
that they've shaved points. Yeah.
They've proven that people have done,
there's a guy who just got out of jail
for that. Yeah. The referee. Right? Yeah.
And I had a friend who, um, who
was a rough day, but they did this.
I thought it was so classless.
They would get first class
tickets and sell them back,
getting checks cashed them in and get
coached tickets and pocket the money.
That's, that's kind of fucking low
life sleazy. Yeah. That's, you know,
it's not living your life either. What
do you get sit in first class? Fuck it.
I know you didn't have the ticket before,
but I think you should be allowed to
do it. I don't see a problem with it.
I feel like, uh, if you're the one who,
uh, wants to sit in coach and you want to,
we'd rather have the money.
I feel like you should be able to do that.
I just think it's a lack of class, so it's
a little sleazy, but no, you know what,
I take that back.
I don't even think it's a little sleazy.
It's like some people like to take it on
board with you. Joe Rogan. I rare they,
some people don't mind coach.
What if he's a little tiny guy and it'll
gets a window seat and he just kind of
curl up? I mind coach. You do. You do.
Oh, I don't see, so that's for you.
It drives you crazy. If he can't go
back there anymore, I can't do it.
It's the only thing about it. I just
don't give a fuck. I always fly for,
I paid more for my ticket to
Australia then I made, I did.
I did. I worked two weeks. I made
less money. Just didn't give a fuck.
I wonder to fly First Class Dad.
So Alaria s that's hilarious.
That is a total dom. I
rare or move, oh my age,
it gets such a kick out of it.
Oh, that's so funny. Well that's,
but again, I hate to say this, but that
it really is why you're so funny still.
It's like there's a, you know, we were
just talking about it the other day,
me and Tripoli,
we're talking about how a lot of comics
that we liked back when we started,
you know, they kind of sort of drift away
from it. You know, like even the greats.
Like look at Steve Martin. He doesn't
do stand up. Stopped a long time ago.
You know, Robin Williams, like we'll
occasionally do stand up, you know,
but you think about the people
that you really admired back then.
It's not that many of them that
I like really active still,
but the ones that are like,
a lot of times they change radically.
Like their acts change.
They,
they kind of drift away from
whatever it was that made them good.
They just sort of get this weird sense
of complacency or something like that.
I don't know what happened. And also you,
they, they run out of juice. You know?
And when I'm not, to me, I consider
myself the oldest young comedian.
I don't even mean I really don't
feel old. I feel young. I feel,
and I'm lucky that I hang out with
guys a lot younger than me. I,
I absorbed that and energy, you know what
I mean? You know, you included. I mean,
it's just the, uh, I,
I love being around that and cause I
find that not to put my generation down,
but a lot of them are fucking bitter and
bitterness goes nowhere. Yeah, exactly. So
it's just like,
like the unnecessary anger yelling out
and smacking your stick on the ground.
Yes, exactly. Realize it for
what is it that makes you bitter?
You're unhappy with your success will
do something about it, you know? I mean,
barring your physical health and
unforeseen circumstances that can't be
controlled, most people have a little
leeway room to, for improvement.
And the bitterness is not fucking
helping yet. Just this fucking guy.
You told me this guy deserves
a sitcom. I tell you, this guy,
I middled for him in Cincinnati.
Do not follow me.
Pat Cooper. Yeah. Yeah. He,
and he was thinking, you know,
I liked the guy, but he's,
you know, he's really angry.
He's telling me he's trying to,
he's thinking I'm too stupid to
realize what he's doing. He's gone.
He's fucking kids today.
These cocksuckers they got five minutes.
They got a sitcom. I've been around 40
years. But you're a good kid. I mean,
he throw it like that.
That's supposed to keep Pique my interest
and I don't have a fucking Citco like,
oh, well maybe I should tell you
something. Maybe you're not right.
That guy was an interesting guy.
Is he still around? Yeah, I mean,
I can't hear anymore, so it's
kinda tough. Oh, that sucks.
He used to go on stern and rant and rave,
go fucking crazy and yell at people
and it's just like, oh my God. Like,
listen to them get wound up. But this,
there's an element of sadness in it,
you know? Yeah. It's an
element of a burns. A lot of
bridges. Some of those guys,
he got mad at the Sopranos,
you know, getting any of you.
But what did he get mad as a promise for?
I don't know.
They didn't give him big enough parts or
some shit and they didn't get, you know,
whatever it was. It's
like, you know what I mean?
I love that rite of passage for Italians
that we were all supposed to be in the
sopranos. What the fuck? They only
got, they got a cast of 20 people.
There's a lot more
Italians, you know? Well,
I think there's a lot of people in that
show that also had not really done a lot
of acting before.
Like Stevie van Zandt,
Little Steve and Bruce
Springsteen and our friend.
I mean our buddy. But it was
Joe. It was, they were, they,
they had a core of real actors and they
had types and some of the types like
Steve developed into real good
actors, you know? But I mean,
that's what the show was.
It was the core of 80 Falco and you
came to Defini and Michael Imperioli
periodically, those guys. And then
they, I, that's the way they cast it.
Yeah.
But I think what the appeal was,
one of the appeals was that these people
that were in these peripheral roles
that really shined and
benefited from it greatly. Our,
like our friend Steve Sherpa,
Steve was not like an experience actor.
He was booking the Riviera when
we met him. He's a great guy.
I fucking love that guy.
But he went from doing that to
being a really successful actor,
boom like that, but a hard worker too. He
and capitalized on it and he, you know,
he's smart. Steve's
are very smart guy. So,
but my point is that other people saw
that and go, look, this fucking guy,
he was over.
He wasn't even jealous of me,
so it wasn't blown.
We're told me I could do such a much
better detailed job with that role,
that role.
I was cool.
It sounded like a little bit of
Quincy Italian and I was having twins.
You lift your finger prints
that it sounded like dice.
Oh,
I'm morphing.
I'm a bunch of fucking characters
over the top. Oh, speaking of dice,
I saw blue jasmine. Did you
see blue jasmine, woody Allen.
Woody Allen Fascinates me, man.
Oh yeah. He's fucking fascinating.
He's the reason I got in the
though. Really? Yeah. When I
was a little kid. Um, he's,
he makes a new movie, like
basically every year, you know,
and they're going to blue. He writes them
all himself and they're fucking good.
This blue jasmine was a good movie.
Um, he's one of the guys. I mean,
I think he's a creeper for sure. I
mean, that whole thing with, yeah.
Daughter was just in, I don't,
I don't want to judge. I'm
trying to be a nice guy,
but I don't think he looked at her as
a daughter. I don't know what happened.
Whatever, whatever. I'd
have no idea. You know what?
You got to got to admire him for,
she's not even hot, so you can't see,
I can't say he left his
wife for a hot young chick.
She's fucking holier than his way. Oh, I
guess. But she's young. It's different.
Um, anyway, you just try to help
them be, yeah. What was I saying?
So his movie, so I saw, this is how
I got to my woody Allen resurgence.
I saw at midnight in Paris. Did you
see that one? Yeah, it's fucking good.
It's a good movie. So
it's interesting. Yeah.
You know what you got to see though
some of the love and death checking out
because it, the fucking jokes are
hilarious. I think I have seen it.
I think that the French revolution,
the Russian French war,
I don't remember what it was about. I
saw it a long time ago. I saw a sleeper.
I saw, um, uh, Annie Hall.
I seen a lot of his little or your
gas metronic in love and death.
A Napoleon says to Diane Keaton, he
goes, how do you think of me as a man?
She goes,
I think at your best,
but
these kinds of jokes.
Oh, what a great line. A line
after line moving none other ones.
Your best bet. It's been a
minute. It goes, uh, you have
beautiful skin. She goes,
yes.
And it covers my entire body.
Well,
a midnight in Paris was really good.
And what's interesting about it is that
Owen Wilson plays woody Allen. Oh Wow.
Woody Allen can't play Woody Helen.
Yeah. He used to get the show on Wilson.
Exactly how he's doing.
Well,
he's not going new Yorkie.
He's going all the way Brooklyn,
but he's basically that guy,
this nebbishy hotkeys.
His wife is fucking around on him. It's
always in, in woody Allen's movies,
someone always is having an affair right
under somebody's nose and it's chaos
and you find out, well you,
you were fucking this guy.
Right. In the other world,
I mean, get over it. It's not
that big a deal like that.
The way that people behave,
almost like as if he wishes that that
would be how people would behave at all
sexual indiscretions.
Right.
It's almost like he's flavoring
the world with a this diet.
Get them off the hook. What's it? Yeah,
because it's a very unnatural, like the,
the anger and reaction is people have,
it's like everything is real.
Except when it comes to like real
emotions dealing with loss or infidelity,
like then it becomes like,
well, get over it. I was right.
Dare you. You had to know.
I didn't know, you know. Okay,
Harry, I was cheating. You know?
It's like one of those things and
the guy's like, I can't believe this,
and he leaves, but it's so unrealistic.
It's like everybody's like, whatever,
get over it. But in blue, jasmine
is another one that the, the uh,
Alec Baldwin Character,
I don't want to give a spoiler alert,
but the reason why I brought it
up is dice is really good in it.
He's really good. He plays this
given to her. It was really short.
I like them short reason why he didn't
probably get any awards because it was
probably, oh his, his thing was your movie
was too short. No, no. His, his role.
He should've had a bigger part in it.
No, no, I think it was perfect. I mean,
it was a complex sort of a
role. It was, it was believable.
There was a lot of, there was a lot
of good acting in that goddamn movie.
Cate Blanchett, the one woman who's
the lead is fucking sensational.
You Know Sean Penn? Yes. Yeah.
When he said to me one night were at the
Improv and he just got a great memory
for comedy.
He said he remembered on all bitten and
he started telling me about it and I go,
all right,
if we're going to talk about comedy,
you gotta tell me what it was like
to work with Woody Allen. He said,
I'm glad you asked me that. He gave
me one note, the whole film. I said,
what was it? He goes, that last
scene you did. Uh, nothing was right.
That was done. That's the only fucking
note. He had only direct nothing.
Nothing in that scene
was right. Wow. Yeah.
Well, he's a master filmmaker. He's just
a weird guy. He's him. He's a genius.
Master filmmaker. Does blue
jasmine movies fucking really good?
I'd have to say he's the best writer.
And then Larry David for comedy
in my, in my opinion, you know,
you mean like joke writing or comedy
writing, right. Just common. Imovie and I,
Larry,
obviously
it has not made the graduation to to
film. Like what are you, what he did,
he shouldn't.
His stuff is so good.
And curb your enthusiasm.
Just don't fuck with it and leave
it right there so that, that,
that let them do whatever
the fuck he's doing.
Let them make that exactly how he's
making it. Don't touch it. I watch
a Seinfeld episode last night that
with the man's ear, the bra for men,
the Bro and I had a prostate exam and I,
when I, when I was going to pee next,
it was going to be blood. Right, right.
It was really fucking like I was,
it was really like fucking horrible.
I was like lightheaded and Shit and Jerry
was on the phone telling me about the
fun about this episode before it happened
and we were fucking crying, laughing.
Just the idea of Jerry Stiller's tits
made us laugh for fucking five minutes.
What is this? I'm confused. What else do
you, pink blood. Oh, because I didn't see,
I didn't want to laugh. Oh, I'm
saying I didn't explain it right.
I didn't want to laugh. I come back from
the hospital, I'm in this bed, man, Moon,
fucking lightheaded or all Pale and shit.
And we started talking and he starts
telling me about this fucking, anyway,
I just reminded me of it because I
saw the episode last night and it's so
fucking brilliant. You
know the he, yeah, he
like everybody loves Raymond,
which was like a really standard,
like good quality sitcom. They had an
eight plot, basically maybe a B plot.
Seinfeld had a, B, c, d, You know
what I mean? Just ridiculous.
Like Craig Kramer hits a golf
ball and it goes into the whales,
the blowhole and you know, they're
like, you know what I mean?
Like everything is connected and
how he did it was fascinating.
22 minutes and clean and
Larry David's genius,
but his best work is curby
enthusiasm in my opinion.
It's Seinfeld is really good,
but curby enthusiasm and takes it to
the one where he had the water bottle in
his pants and he,
and I didn't want to tell the whole story.
Hooker Carpool came and
tell you the stories that we
know that came out of Lowry
spoiled him that came out of Larry. I'm
not getting enough credit for Seinfeld.
I really believe that because
everybody would get credit.
George got credit for playing him
and you know, can Jason Alexander,
he's a terrific actor, but he was so much
in the background. He thought, fuck this,
I'm doing a show and he had
the power to do it. You know,
he put up his own money for that.
Jason Alexander is a weird one because
nothing's really clicked for him since
doing that shit.
Who's so fucking good too.
He was so good on that show and now he's
taken to wearing a hairpiece. I know.
And you know I saw the one last night
where where he wore a hairpiece on a show.
It's a joke as a joke and now he's wearing
one in real life. It's a what's like,
I dunno what,
unless you're going to do it like Carl
Reiner did where you just take it off
sometime and where I'm trying,
I think it's funny cause they
going to try to fool anybody.
He's not trying to fool anybody.
You can't because everybody
knows that he was already bald,
and I think he just likes the way
it looks better, which good for him.
But why you worrying so much about what
you look like? It's a little weird.
I said, just wear a hat.
I don't wear anything.
It's not like it affects
his performance in some way.
Like if growing your hair
made you smarter somehow.
Like imagine if like
hair was like muscles.
Like the bigger your muscles get stronger,
you get the longer hair gets smarter,
you get,
well,
I could get wanting to have more hair
and if you could wear a toupee that would
make you smart.
It might've given the people were that
were that simple that you just had to
fiber optic to pay and you put on it
would mimic the effects of having a full
head of hair as far as your intelligence
goes or grow it even further when you
remember what goes on with the ego. Who
these guys, you know, and Jay Jason was,
I remember being on that set and he was
upset because he never wanted an Emmy.
Oh God. He won grammy awards. Dude,
I was on a set of news radio wants and
everybody was complaining. It was dark.
It was like everybody was
bummed out because our ratings
were down and there was,
you know, it was like, God, we
can't get on Thursday night,
but this show goes on right before friends
or right after friends and blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah. And I remember thinking
like, we're on a sitcom. Oh yeah.
Oh lucky you are to be on a sitcom.
And it's a really funny one.
And we're not appreciating it as it's
happening. Right as it's going on.
We're wishing we were number one
instead of whatever the fuck we were.
We weren't doing well like
news radio never did well.
It didn't do really well
until it was syndicated.
They didn't know how to use you at all.
News radio did. Oh, I, some great parts.
I think they could have used you
more. Oh, that's very nice to you.
But that's just cause you love me.
I think they use me the perfect amount
and we consider the fact that we have so
many characters. Andy, Dick,
Vicky Lewis, Steven Root,
candy Alexander, Phil Hartman,
Dave Foley, Maura Tierney,
me the fucking shit. Yeah, that's a
lot. It was an eight person castle,
a lot of fucking people at 22 minute
show and you're bouncing everything back
and forth and you got two,
well three monsters on the cast.
You got Phil Hartman who's a
monster day, Foley, a monster,
and Andy Dick was a monster.
So those were like the go to guys for
like carrying scenes and big moments and
you know, I would come in with
something wacky on occasion,
some wacky thing that I
would do. I thought they were
great about divvying it up.
The one who got the slight,
and my opinion is candy Alexander,
the black truck that was on the
show. She's a bad ass actress, man.
That girl is a powerful, strong actress
and I just don't think they ever really,
totally got her. I don't think she
had enough roles where it was like,
but you know a bunch of white dudes
from Harvard. Right. So sexy blast,
we'll show you did right before the
hardball or a piece of Shit. Yeah,
that was cool. You got it right
away. I got lucky, that's for sure.
The two things that were the
luckiest that I ever got was uh,
getting hardball and from getting
hardboiled, getting news radio, you know,
the fear factor thing was a more of a
response to not wanting to be in the
acting world anymore.
You know,
when I took fear factor for the money
a but also be because I knew it wasn't,
I didn't,
I wouldn't have to deal with actors.
I wasn't going to have to deal with
scripts and the creative aspect of bad
comedy because you go from a show like
news radio, which is a really good show.
Try finding another really good
show. Good luck. Oh, I know.
I've been on them and I read from
something they would just, it was painful.
They were bad.
It just clumsy and clunky.
Joey got fired from a show that was
written for me. I couldn't play.
And the guy that was so fun and you know,
it was so happy when it went down
in flames because it was so bad.
They hired like this real actors guy.
Dan had day and he couldn't make
it work and it's just a day.
And why do I know that name?
He was the father and clueless.
It was sheriff's father
and includes. Wow. But uh,
would you do another
sitcom? Yeah, definitely.
If Paul Simms was going
to do another Sitcom,
the guy who made news radio
is you wanting to do it.
I almost did another one at his.
I'd love to work with you man.
I did a pilot of a show called
um, overseas. It was a pilot.
I played like some guy that was on some
other country for some strange reason I
got stuck over there. So, but
uh, he's just a brilliant guy.
It's just such an out of the box guy.
I know there's other out
of the box guys out there,
you know to think the guy who,
uh, what's his name? Dan Harmon,
the guy who makes community,
like everybody's saying the community,
it's just like a hundred times better
than seats. And now that he's back,
he's back and chase. He's
gone. Yeah, he Chevy chase.
Yeah, that was the other thing.
Um, he's a happy go. Lucky Guy,
Huh? Yeah, it doesn't seem to, Huh?
What's the guy's name?
Um,
the, the soup, uh, Joel Mchale, sorry.
Great Guy Too. By the way. I feel like
a Dick for not remembering your name,
but I blame the weed.
Uh,
Joel Mchale was on Opie and Anthony and
he was talking about Chevy chase that he
just really didn't want to be there. How
do you get insulted that your own roast,
you get insulted their rose. It's a roast.
You have, they're going to say things.
It's supposed to hurt your feelings.
Exactly. That's why you don't get a roast.
Do you gotta do organize around?
So I liked them.
I liked them when I did them and
I did, um, in the, uh, with those,
like the real old guy,
I was like the young kid and it was Milton
Berle and all those guys in the 80s.
And I liked them because they were
like the real originators of the roast.
Now how, how much can you talk about
how big Cloris Leachman is? Kindness,
you know what I mean? It's like
how far is it? Is that come out?
Is that like a big part of roasts and
now for the mandatory and how big is
Cloris?
Leachman?
Actually it came up about fucking
20 times when I went to see, um,
uh, Pamela Anderson Roast it. I think
it was, uh, or no, maybe it was her sag.
I forget. I always get
those two mixed up. And uh,
they just relentlessly
did the same fucking joke.
You could drive a car into
Pamela Anderson's Conn and
this is that, you know,
it was like, oh, this is so not true. I've
seen that video. Tommy leave video. Yeah.
You couldn't, tiny little
thing. Yeah, they got all
kind of cars. Are you driving?
I can't jerk off to a video like that.
No. No, not like too big. Well, no,
just a married couple that I don't want
to, I ain't want to see people that are,
you know, like out of this
world. Not Real, real people.
Like our prostitute friend. I haven't
been with a prostitute and wow, how long?
Couple of days. But uh,
what time is it? No, I,
I took blood pressure medication
about two years ago and it made me,
like we were saying, made me
less Italian, a more Irish.
Do you think that you would ever be
into doing something to radically change
your health?
Like if someone,
if you took on like someone
who told you what to eat,
gay worked you out every day,
put you through the paces and got
your body into a better shape,
better condition and actually, can I get
in better shape? It's almost impossible.
I mean you're at the top like an Olympic.
We're going to like,
we can wiki all the shit
out wall. Go fine. Tune it,
fine tune it a little bit,
a bit. Know where I am.
I'm totally fucking pleased with,
I love having a gut because I got
something to rest my hands on when I'm
thinking you have my favorite,
my favorite line ever when it comes
to being gay, being in the closet,
you'd go, I wish I was in the
closet just so I could come out.
That's how little I give a fuck.
That was just a line for the show.
I know we did that on stage,
said I wish I was gay just so
I could come out of the closet.
Some exciting look at Todd glass.
He got more press on that fucking
hell and it made her career. Well,
I'll tell you what, when Todd glass
came on the podcast, he real I,
that is the first time I had
talked to him in person since uh,
he came out and I guess you're
supposed to say he seems so relieved
and he was so relieved that he could come
on the Sean beat got barbecued who was
so relieved that we could all do that
together and the giggling and silly and he
wouldn't have to worry about feeling
like he's being attacked whether he was
hiding something. That's a
big thing for those guys, man.
Or for those girls or anybody who is
hiding something like that, you know?
No one should care,
man. No one should care.
You should be able to tell people that
you're into dressing like a girl should
be able to tell the people
that you like to fuck.
I should be able to tell
me whatever the fuck it is.
Ugly your fucking girl
and you were on you. Me,
I fucking jaw. You would be a little
bit uglier than me. It's a little bit,
a little bit more confused me a
little bit. How to check the mail too.
I like to think of a judge.
If I was going to go to uh,
a girl to get a hand job, I might go to
you. Ah, but soft hair I would think.
Yeah. Soft hands. And there's a lot of
like, I'm not blowing anybody though.
That's where I draw the line.
Even if I was a cow.
But if I think the blonde somewhere,
that condom,
it's just like fucking shaking their
hand through a window, you know, come on.
What's going on there? You know, you
need to put your hand on the glass.
You're not really shaking hands.
Yeah.
Someone just going up and down on your
Dick when there's a condom on it. Like,
what is that
weird barrier between you and pleasure?
And we need that because people have
diseases in their mouths and their decks
were gross. People are gross or fucking
gross diseases. There was this hooker,
she's a porn. I love the porn star
fucking theory like everybody takes,
but they never say,
they say just he's a working actor.
I know what I'm saying is that he's a
star. He's not as starting the, anyway,
she came up, she came up to me at the
comedy store, gave me a hug. She goes,
then she Facebook being,
but my ex wife does my Facebook and she
wrote that to tell you that he did sound
okay. Uh, she, she came after me.
She says she would when she went to the
exchange sexual favors for comedy wisdom
and my wife's and said, you know, she
goes, who is my ex wife? She goes,
who is this fucking nut?
I just ripped it up and throw it out
because she's sounding like a whore. I go,
but that's the good thing. Right. Anyway,
she doesn't know you very well know.
Anyway, she did get in touch with me and,
but you know what? She was so fucking
annoying about comedy. It turned me off.
Really? Yeah, because she wanted way more
comedy that I wanted. Anything from her.
Well, when someone that
I saw in a lesbian video,
when someone wants to learn
how to do comedy there,
you know there's a few things you
could tell him, but there's very few.
It's the real thing that they
need to do is go on stage,
go onstage a lot and then
chop it down yourself.
Minimize the amount of words you use,
maximize the impact of those words,
figure those things out and fake.
Find out what it is.
It's funny and unique about you.
Listen to yourself because
a few things you could tell.
Some of them when they want to
go over individual bits with you,
they basically want
you to write their act.
And that happens to a lot of
boyfriends. I mean that's a, it's,
it's a joke that I've heard
used on several different
comedians that are female
that wind up dating men that are also
comedians and then start writing their
acts. I mean, we know guys who have done
it. It happens all the fucking time.
And you know, that's not as fun.
That's, that's weird. That's a weird,
but it's seat.
But then this case is like Thompson Jura
and Christina Palicki where I'm sure
they go over bits with each other,
but they go over bits as peers.
You know what I'm saying?
Like Tom's not rewriting her act.
She's not rewriting Thom Zak. They're both
holds for, yeah. Yes. But that's ideal.
You know,
like,
that's why I love when something like
that happens because people always like to
use that, uh, that thing.
Like that's standby cliche
that two comedians can never
be husband and wife and
be happy to people that are,
you know, in the same position,
the same sort of occupation. They
would just wind up fighting each other.
Tom and Christina get along great
and they're both fucking great.
They're both really funny people.
They're like, you see them together,
the laughing together and they're always
laughing with each other and like they
enjoy each other's company
and they're both really good.
It's so rare when you see something
like that. It's so awesome.
I think that's the aberration. I don't
think it's normal, but it's possible.
It's possible. It's totally
possible. That's what I like.
I liked that it's possible. That ruined
my marriage. Yeah, the competition. Yeah,
because like I was getting hired for
Saturday night live like in 1980 and I got
like three episodes. It's a long
story. It's not even worth it.
Sound like Brian Calendar right now.
I'll do it real big deal.
I was just like the greatest
comedian of all time. No, no,
I didn't mean it like this.
I just put the story was to let,
the story was actually too long,
but anyway, she would come.
I'm not on the fucking show
and I'd come home. She goes,
did you mention me to them? Like,
oh, I'm not. I said, mentioned you.
I don't even have a fucking voice. I
don't even have an agent. You know?
So that was, that really kind of ruined
a lot of things. Yeah, that's rough. Oh,
did you mention me?
I had a friend who got apart and his
girlfriend started crying immediately and
it's like, when is something going to
happen for me? Oh No. It was a, it was so,
it was so uncomfortable to be
around. Yeah, that's, it was,
she was doing it like in front
of me and I was like, okay. Uh,
she was crying in front of you. Oh
yeah. Yeah. He, he, he goes, guess what?
I got the part. Oh. And
she starts crying. Like,
when is something going to happen to me?
I think for some people they're just
not cut out for the pressure of,
of like trying to audition
and go after things.
Like one of the things that people
point out is I'll crazy actresses are,
and actors are, but I think one of
the reasons why they're so crazy,
it's not just that they came here crazy,
but that the process itself is so
terrifying and mind numbing and obsessive
because it's so difficult to get cast
in something so difficult when you
competing against thousands of other
people on a daily basis for a limited
amount of roles and every,
and you're, you know,
you're barely getting by and then
you finally do get something.
I think all those years and
years and years of rejection,
and then you could really fuck with
people's heads. But yeah, it's really bad.
Especially when they're
already a little bit insecure.
They're already a little bit nutty.
They already maybe possibly a little bit
depressed, maybe a little bit chemical,
you know? Yeah. I just
never thought like anybody
else's success diminished me.
Like I didn't think because Eddie Murphy
got 48 hours that if he didn't get it,
I was going to get it. You
know? I just never thought like,
no, you never did. You never had
and you've never had like this, uh,
this is a weird resentment than
a lot of people have towards, uh,
people that they've no relation
to. You know, look, you
fucking this guy, you know,
damn Wayman steam Wayne, since he's a
motherfucker. Damon Wayans ain't got shit.
I was like, you know, why?
What do you care about Damian Wayans is
he hitting to in any way affecting your
path?
I mean, look at your career. Are you,
you have the, you have such a, I mean,
it's such a unique is redundant,
but I mean like,
I could never fucking announced
this. The fights like you do, you,
you're an expert on that shit. What
did he, there's no competition.
You're stand up and mine are so different
to hopefully the only end result is
they're both funny.
We're both very lucky. You know, we're
both very lucky that we figured out our,
our, our path in life.
You know, I just, I'm,
I'm in a weird spot where I'm extremely
lucky because I liked to do a lot of
things. Yeah. And I get lucky that
there's a job for those things.
Like if the UFC didn't exist, I would
watch an exact, I mean if the job,
rather than me being a commentator
didn't exist. If they just,
we just watched fights live and
no one ever talked about it,
I would still be doing the same thing.
I'd be doing the exact same almost. Yeah.
I mean I would, I wish certain wouldn't
be breaking it down for a broadcast,
but I'll be watching every single
one of them. I'd watch everything.
I've watched them live if I could.
I did before I even worked there.
I just got super lucky.
You can hear how happy or doing the,
you can hear it in your voice. You'll
love it. Yeah, I do enjoy it. It's fun,
but I'm, I'm just lucky. I'm
lucky. There's a lot of cool
shit to do in the world.
You know, martial arts is just
one of many cool things. I mean,
I could probably learn new things
forever and ever and always be excited.
Like skateboarding seems like it'd be fun.
I just started learning how to ski.
Skiing is fun. It's exciting. I mean,
I bet it would be really fun to learn
how to play an instrument. You know?
If I had more time, I'd probably pursue
that. I started doing archery recently.
I got these targets. I set them up in my
backyard. I bought a bowtech experience.
60 pound poll, compound bow. Oh Dude.
It shoots things like a laser beam.
What's amazing? Come on. Oh please,
come on over. Let's have a boat party.
Please hide those from the kids.
They can't touch it. They could never
pull it back in the first place.
I mean hours a locked up the the bow.
It's so incredibly difficult to pull
back 60 pounds like he a grown man,
like yourself. Not like me. Of course
I could just pull that bitch back.
Flip for real.
The really strong guys actually use a 70
pound bull beau guy in here yesterday.
It's probably 20 pounds lighter than me.
He actually uses a 70 pound bow,
so he's used a bow that's 10
pounds a stronger than mine,
but I'm just learning how to do it now.
I'm not really concerned with it being
like the fastest boat in the world.
I just enjoy hitting targets.
I have these rubber, um,
squares like set up at different parts
of my yard and I get up on this little
platform in my yard. I get the dogs out
of the yard and shoot arrows. It's fun,
man. It's really exciting. It's when
you hit a target that you want to hit,
like whatever reason, you know your,
your, your body goes Ooh. Yeah. It's like,
it's more exciting than
shooting a basketball into
a net like basketball, new.
Ned's always been exciting like playing
horse like three points. Whoa. But,
but a fucking 50 yard
bullseye with an arrow.
There's something like it goes to
your DNA, some Robin Hood. Shit.
It's leftover third some watermelons
in the backyard. That sounds fun. Yeah,
but watermelons or food. I don't
want to waste food. I feel guilty.
I can't be wasted food. But I'll fuck
up a squirrel that got catch slipping.
I'll eat to squirrel that I catch from my
backyard. What do you think about that?
That rhino that that's in the news
fucked up. Fucked up. Fucked up. Crazy,
ridiculous. Doesn't make
any sense. Makes me sick.
I don't like the idea for you don't
know the story. There's a black rhino.
They audition, they auctioned off a a
right to hunt. This black rhino and the,
the winning bidder paid
$350,000 to kill this, uh,
endangered Anna. That's fucked
up. And because of that,
$1 million is going to go to the
preservation of the black rhino.
I think that's ridiculous.
I think that guy's an asshole.
I don't care if that money goes to the
preservation would, this guy should do,
if he's really concerned, this guy,
this hunter is go hunt with a camera,
goddammit.
Go get a really good close up photograph
of this thing and know that you could
have killed it. No, you've could have
killed it. You don't have to kill you.
And then while you're there, go shoot some
shit that you can kill your in Africa.
Go shoot some wild buck.
Go shoot some a ward hogs.
Go shoot some things that the
locals will eat, you know?
And then it actually benefits the
people there. If you go to Africa,
like I saw Matt Hughes
who's a former UFC champion,
one of the greatest mixed
martial arts fighters ever.
He's also a big hunter and he went to
Africa with his son and he took all these
photos of them shooting these animals
and people just were all up his ass.
They were just shitting all
over him and tell him, you know,
he's an asshole and he's not even eating
that food. These are trophy hunters.
He shot so many animals.
Well they don't realize is when you go
there and you do something like that,
they take the money that you use to pay
for your trip and that money goes to
preserve these animals.
Then the meat from hunting,
that animal goes to feed these local
villagers. Like they get very happy,
like they're excited. They get all
this lean, they don't have guns,
and so they get all this lean protein
free from these hunters and they get it
every day because every
day they're bringing in new
hunters and everyday they're
harvesting new animals.
Like people don't like it because
they feel like it should be a direct
relationship.
You should shoot a deer,
then you eat the deer or give some of
the meat out to your friends or something
like that,
which I kind of agree with.
I don't want to be the guy that's like
going somewhere to kill animals for a
bunch of different people.
But if you did,
that's actually a very
selfless thing to do. I mean,
he's enjoying the hunting aspect of it,
but he's also donating all these,
all this meat to poor people,
but nobody wants to see it that way.
Everybody has this black or white
thing when it comes to animals.
Either you love animals and respect
them and you don't shoot them,
or you hate animals and you
were fucking evil person.
Even if you both have the same diet.
I mean the idea that someone would want
to kill that thing when we know there's
only like a few thousand of them
left, that's fucking crazy. You know?
I hope so many steps in and I hope,
I mean really that's something that
the president should talk about.
The president should have a fucking
joint conference where he talks about
seaworld and killing black
rhinos and B, just say, what did,
what would we do if someone came here
from looking? They sought off the horn.
Oh my God. That's fucked
man. Know why? Right? Yeah.
Because Chinese dudes think that it
makes your dick hard on her pills.
They haven't figured out if I
angry at, I guess, you know.
No Way Rhino Horn is as good as Viagra,
by the way. You know what Rhino Horn is?
Its hair. You're eating hair?
Yeah. That horn his hair.
It's thickly knotted hair that grows into
a point. Yeah. It's not like an antler,
like this deer antler here.
This antler falls off every year
and you find them on the ground.
They're called sheds and they grow
every year and then you know, they,
they butt heads with those
things on that side bar. Well,
that's not the case of the Rhino
with a rhino. It's actually hair.
It's like the same thing to fingernails.
It may not. It's like Keratin.
It's kind of crazy shit man. But the, the
idea that anybody would pay to do that,
like don't do it man. Don't fucking
kill rhinos. These aren't in the,
like there's been an argument
against killing elephants, but,
and there's certain areas of Africa where
they have an overpopulation issue with
elephants and they've taken
to assassinating elephants.
They've taken a hunting though.
It's really freaky because
they're bringing in hunters
and it was a TV show on
the other night where this guy went to
Africa and just snuck up on an elephant
and shot it in the fucking head. And it
doesn't seem right. It seems fucked up.
Did you ever play with every bulls?
No. No. Never played it. Right.
The gave the food to the villagers
and they were saying this though, uh,
years food. Cool. So yeah, I guess,
but there's something about elephants.
It freaks me out. It freaks me out.
They kill elephants. Wales. Yeah. To me,
elephants are smart as shit.
They recognize each other when they
haven't seen each other in 20 years.
Did you know that? Really? Yup. That's
the whole memory thing then. Yes.
Yes. Will they have really
good minds. Their minds are.
They're much more complex than we
ever thought they gonna. In fact,
they can create art.
You can teach an elephant to use a
paintbrush and they can draw themselves.
Really? You never seen that? Oh
my God, wait, do you see this?
I'm going to show you something. You
know what? I'm going to believe a thrill.
It's an elephant painting himself and
when you see it and how good it is,
it's like what my five year old would do.
It's like a five year old human,
I don't know if that
represents like the same,
if that's the same intelligence is
like a small child, but God damn it,
it seems like there's something really
serious going on behind the scenes there.
They're able to draw themselves.
Dot Merera they're able to self portrait.
Pull ahead because there's a
long ass video, but look at this.
He's using his and you would think,
okay, this is bullshit. This is fake. No,
he really is.
He's his own trunk and he's
trying to draw what he sees.
Look at, he's drawing tusks. Dom
Arrera. He's drawing the legs.
It's like perfect and like how he got
it perfect, but like fucking incredible.
Incredible. That's an intelligent
animal and in my opinion,
hunting that animal should be,
Aye. Look how good that is.
God dammit. And saying that should be the
last resort for real. Yes. It's for real.
Like Shit.
It should be the last resort when it
comes to preserving these animals.
That's ridiculous.
What they should do is figure out a way
to either move them to areas where there
are populations have drastically decreased
or find some way to give them some
food that makes them less
likely to get pregnant. I mean,
who knows what strategies
they could come up with,
but shooting them seems really sad to me.
Okay.
Yeah. That's amazing. That's super smart.
And that's smarter than a wolf. Okay.
That's unbelievable.
Yeah.
I mean that's the argument against
killing wolves is that they're smart and
they're very much like dogs and you know,
but that's way smarter than a fucking
both. That's smarter than a monkey man.
That's smart as shit. How smarter these
God damn things. Okay, cool. Yeah,
it's interesting to watch you do it.
This is not bullshit. Look them. Do it.
See now you can see the actual
full elephant. Look at this.
I mean this is utterly incredible.
Utterly incredible.
Eight every in a bag.
It,
it's amazing. Wow. Yeah. I Dunno man.
Then the relationship with
the relationship between
you're going to die. Nope.
The relationship that we have between
other animals is a very strained one.
It's very strange how we,
because we have some animals that we
use for food and some animals that we
decide to use as a resource and you
know, it's, it's all very cruel.
I don't understand the rationalization.
Sometime between with
animals you picked to kill,
to eat in the sense that
people are pescatarians.
What makes them think fish
are happy to be on a hook and,
well the idea is that fish
don't take care of their young.
Okay.
Dov or dolphins swim fish. Yeah.
Fish don't take care of the young.
So they're like, fuck these fish.
Look how good that is tomorrow.
He true fucking flowers in his, in his
trunk. Oh, it's insane. It's insane.
It's insane. How, how talented
this elephant as a drawing. I mean,
that's better than most people
could probably draw now.
I think if you kill that,
that that's murder. Yup. Look at this.
Look at this thing. Painting the sky, man.
Are you fucking shitting me?
It's painting a word.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. This is the sad, so
sad. It's just sad. I Dunno. Youtube.
It's under a, if you guys want to see
it, it's under elephant's painting.
Elephants suit. That's the,
remember the name of him.
He was writing his name and he
knows how to write his name. I mean,
this is insanity. Do you kill
that thing? That's murder.
That's like a big giant person. Or
sometimes it's just, it doesn't,
that doesn't make any sense to me.
Whatever that is.
It doesn't make any sense to
me. Mindblowing. Mindblowing.
Unbelievably fascinating. But to
those villagers, one years food,
we just eat [inaudible]. I mean,
I can't fucking believe that.
It's hard to believe.
Yeah.
I think if I walk out of here
and I hear you guys laughing, no
intelligent animals, intelligent
animals are, uh, am I, in my opinion,
we should treat them very differently
than we treat everything else. Well,
I never believed that
animals couldn't think.
I always believe they always sit in with
dogs. Don't think it's just instinct.
I don't buy that. No
animals. Fucking thank man.
Of course they think they just
don't think as well as we do.
So we like to say they don't think they're
just, they're limited. I mean their,
their, their bodies are about survival
and breeding survival and breeding.
And those are the only things they
don't create culture. You know,
we become ultra complex because
we create culture and we,
because we have the ability
to manipulate our environment.
So that's why we categorize dolphins in
this weird gray area that allows us to
enslave them because they can't create
culture and because they can't manipulate
their environment,
they don't have fingers,
we don't see any evidence of
their intelligence. But meanwhile,
there's tons of scientific evidence of
the fact that they can communicate with
each other, that they have a language lab
ILX that they have family communities,
that they recognize each other long
distances that they pulled together.
I mean it's, it's an, it's an intelligent
thing that you're in slaving. It's all,
it is. It's, there's no if, ands, or
buts about it. It's a bad argument.
Whether it's an Orca,
you know,
orchids are fucking even
smarter than dolphins there.
There's super intelligent animals.
It's madness. It's madness,
it's total madness.
And when you see an elephant that can
paint a fucking picture better than most
of us in this room, what does that, that
that elephant paints better than you?
That's the most phenomenal thing I've
ever seen an animal do. It's incredible.
It's incredible. Have you ever
seen chimps spelled her name?
Chimps can spell their
name. Uh, for candy.
They teach them how to solve complex
puzzles and they give them candy and then
they can remember the order of files.
They can count things from one to seven,
one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven. And they, they, you know,
like the images will go blank and
they'll remember which one was one,
which one was two. And we'll
reveal like each and development,
make it flip over in order. Something
that I would struggle with. Sure. Yeah.
He's locking up chimps is conti to
putting them in a zoo is stupid.
They should have them in an area where
they live in the wild and observe them.
That's it.
All this other stupid shit where even
if they make enough wild that it seems
wild to them. Yeah. Maybe if
you have a really large place,
but like that lady in Connecticut that
was living with one and the one they
wound up biting her friend's face off,
that is criminal negligence.
I mean that's no different than building
bombs in your yard and your friend
comes over and you're below your
friend's face off was so fucking Straw.
Just not just strong, but
violent as fuck. And guess what?
She gave the chimp Xanax. Really? Yeah.
She gave the chimps Xanax and
wine bitch was crazy. Well,
she had this 200 pound murderous monster
living in her house is yoked up super
monster. He was in the, he was in a
cage. Right? It's where a diaper. Yeah.
I don't think he was in a cage.
Oh,
I thought he was in a cage when he reached
out from her. No, no, no, no, no, no. He,
he lived in, uh, he, he wanted
around and do whatever you want it,
but the woman was babysitting
them. No. What happened was the,
a woman's friend came over.
A woman's friend came over.
The chimp did not like the woman's friend.
The woman's friend kept him from her.
Maybe.
Maybe he thought of her as his girlfriend.
So he just attacked and just
ripped her apart. Holy Shit.
Look at the muscles on this fucking
things. Are you kidding me? Man?
That looks like who some are Paul Harris,
but even more muscular.
He's definitely on it. I could see him
using kettle bells and battle ropes.
Zombie ones.
Chimps gives zero fucks.
That's one of the scariest animals in
the world. If it's trying to get you,
because if they got ahold of you,
like you might be able to even fight
off a bear to the point where the bear
decides like, you're too crazy. Fuck it.
I'll leave them alone if the bear
wasn't hungry, if it's a nutty bear,
but a chimp is not going to let you win,
you know they're,
they're having a contest with you and
they're going to bite your fingers off.
They're going to beat you census,
they're going to pull your genitals off.
They'll pull your pants
off and bite your ass hole.
It's like they know how to hurt you.
They're smart.
I think it would be one of the most
terrifying animals have to face in an
encounter.
Yeah.
I'd probably take my chances with
like something like a shark before it
champions. People have lived, I mean,
people live in chimpanzee fights too,
but they get ripped apart.
Sometimes people they get rescued.
It's usually in preserves that all
this stuff happens too, by the way,
in the wild. It's very rare that
a chimpanzee attacks a person,
but did you see that picture that I had
on Twitter the other day of a Jaguar
that had got killed with his bare hands?
This is,
we don't make men like this anymore.
[inaudible].
It's an old black and white
Joda motherfucker killed
a Jaguar with his hands.
Bare hands. It says it's on my Twitter
page. It's just I think yesterday. Yeah.
Look at this motherfucker,
Carl eight glee. I salute you.
You fucking savage of a man.
You real man.
You make me feel weak as a bitch.
Look at that. God Damn savage,
he killed a leopard with his hands.
That's how you know.
That's how you know you can hold up
under pressure when you're duking it out
with a cat. That's a big cat
too. It's not a big leopard.
What do you think that
weighs? 20 yeah. No,
that's not that heavy. That's
like 70 pounds. 60 70 pounds.
The neck or you see how, look at,
look at it compared to his body. No,
it doesn't say how he did it.
At least I didn't read it.
Look at it in relationship to his body.
You know it's, it's a perspective thing.
If you brought the head all
the way down to the ground,
the head is a suspended about where his
knee is. It's hanging by its back feet.
If you brought the head all the way to
the ground, it really wouldn't even be as,
as long as his, uh, his most of his upper
body. Why was he even engaged with you?
And it must've his lower body, right. Did
he come after him? He had attacked him.
Oh, jumped him. Try to eat them.
People had been selling ever since I been
putting up pictures from trail cameras,
people have been sending me trail camera
photos of mountain lions that they
catch in their yards or mountain lions
that they catch near their house.
A guy sent me one today from Florida
of these two fucking muscular Florida
panthers. You know, I've never seen a
panther. Never seen a mountain lion. No.
I've seen my online, but I've never
seen a panther the same animal.
It's a smaller though,
isn't it? Um, maybe,
maybe it doesn't get into food or maybe
I was in the keys a couple of weeks ago
when we were talking about that,
cause they have the signs up.
It'd be aware of them, you know? Well,
like most fucked up things in Florida,
the population is growing.
The population of fucked up
people in Florida is growing.
The population of fucked
up cats is growing.
The population of alligators is growing.
Population of bath salts,
abusers is growing. Foreign
is fucking crazy. And Don,
my ray was going to be
there this weekend lady.
That can segue now that's a segue.
I want to put that in my driveway.
Just scared to go to people. He, Brian,
can we set up a Gopro on the Werewolf
please? We do that. Let's figure that out.
That's your next project that is fucking
tearing apart from the Werewolf drop
found every time I walk in here though
is do you see a picture of Eddie Bravo,
Eddie Bravo radio. Use The podcast
studio the other night. Powerful.
Jamie stepped in and saved the day.
He Bravo's computer crashed and Eddie
called me up like last minute and he's
like, dude, I'm fucked. Like the
podcast is in a half an hour, you know,
and my computer's crashed and I didn't.
So he came over and use this place. Um,
but when he did, he took all his
clothes off and took a photo of him.
Fucking the Werewolf pull
that shit up is Eddie Bravo.
He will commit to things in a
way that very few people can.
I'd love this fucking
dude. He's so crazy. This,
this is a total Eddie Bravo picture
that he would send you like this, uh,
epitomizes why I love this dude is one
of the reasons why he got a job as a
writer on the man show.
And he probably has crazy lucky
look at least committing to it.
He screamed at the top of his lungs,
all of his clothes are off and he's
banging the Werewolf from behind.
It would have been a little bit better
if he had like a little bit more of an
angle so we could actually see his
ass cheeks. So we know he's really,
really naked. He's so crazy
though. Look at him. He's so silly.
I love that too. Powerful.
Eddie Bravo. So, uh, yeah,
we're going to let other people
do it too. So you know, any,
all of our friends who do podcasts,
I know Tommy wanted to use it at one
point in time and Dunkin's going to use it
like whenever they need to do shit
on with cameras and what have you.
I think it makes this place
more the merrier. The more, uh,
I feel like the more good
conversations we have in this place,
I feel like it's soaks into the
wall. So it's good in a jail. Yeah.
I love this fucking place. When I
come here, I feel like I'm at home.
I feel like this is our, uh, our
weird little, oh, it's very cool.
Portal to the rest of the world. I
like to lift factory the, you know,
but just for the comfort of being on the
stage, I'm comfortable. Well, that's a,
also a stage. He performed that for
like two and a half decades. Right.
That's a great place. So yes, since
the late eighties. Yeah. Jesus Christ.
That's even more, right. What does
that 46, 40. Yeah. Jesus Christ.
Yeah. 46. 2014. Oh,
26 rather. Yeah. Yeah. I say you
are. I'm 46. That's what I meant. Uh,
I graduated in 85. I was 21,
so it's probably at the lift.
I was 89 and 90 doing half talking
and half a adding my age on there.
So what year I was,
um, in 86 I was not 21.
I was 21 in 88. Joe, wait, here we
do a full photo. Come to comedy will,
I mean I can't do math when
you're talking to me. Oh, sorry.
It's still complicated. Full
frontal comedy. 93 I think.
Did we the one in um,
Montreal? No, no, that was uh,
uh Oh that was dangerous zone. That was
also a showtime, right? Yeah, I think so.
I think it must have been 94 then.
That's when don my railroad and I
became pool playing partners. Wow. Oh,
we met in Amsterdam billiards.
So we first found out that we both,
we each played pool. It's right. Total
luck by chance. I was in town doing a Gig.
Don was doing a Gig and we went up by
knocking some balls around together and I
said, you got a good stroke
there, Mr Right Herrera,
you got them out of bed and play
pretty good fella for a comedian.
The all Comedians Pool League is a U.
R e should fear,
um, me. Um, uh, uh,
what's his name from Adam for our please.
Very good. And please very consignments.
Greg Fitzsimmons please. Very
good. There you go. That's good.
And what I was trying to
think of as Craig Anthony,
Craig Anthony from the
movies are Anthony, uh, shit.
Mike Robinson. Kay Robinson. Craig
Anthony. Who's Craig Anthony? Uh,
the guy from breakfast. Someone's
Craig Anthony. Why do I know that name?
Craig Robinson from, yeah, he's
cranky and seeing a fighter.
I didn't drink Robinson. Craig Robinson
from this is the end. Did you see that?
They just see him and this is the end.
That's the little bit of smoothies on the
office, right? James Franco? Yeah. Yeah.
Good guy. He's a poet. Craig. Anthony,
you're thinking of a post that's where is,
yeah, Craig Robinson. Sorry,
Craig. Craig is hilarious. He's,
and he's a really good pool player too.
Apparently Vinny fat Burrito can
play too. Yeah. Yeah. Allegedly.
I've never seen him, but I've heard he
plays really good. Tried to hustle me.
Oh too slick. No Way. Oh,
I got a helical tussle.
Dama rare fucking happen.
You don't have a gambling issue.
Do I love to gamble but I don't gamble
much money. I love gambling on football.
Yeah, it's fun. The juice of it is,
is a riot just gabbing a little spark to
the game and I'm talking like 50 bucks
and nothing that I think that should
be legal man. Oh, it's so stupid.
Bums me out that that's not, I feel like
you should be able to bet at any corner.
You know, there should be some sort
of a way that you could, uh, you know,
like fucking regulate how it
gets taxed or it, you know,
where we can all meet
and gamble on things.
We should be able to
bet against each other.
We should be able to put our money jointly
into something and it gets deposited
into either one of our accounts.
If we win and the government takes a
little piece off the top to make sure it
gets taxed and that's it.
Let people gamble.
You go to any police station and the
have football pools. Yeah. Why not?
What's wrong with that
and not say nothing.
They shouldn't get in trouble for
that either. It's fucking ridiculous.
I'm telling him, uh, Brian Dunning that
I'm doing a podcast. What was he? I now,
yeah. Anyway, that's it.
Dot. Merera that's it.
We got to wrap this bitch up. We got,
it was fun. It's always fun. My brother,
we've been friends a long fucking
time pal. I know. I love that.
It's a great history. Yeah, it's been
a lot of fun. If I had some good times,
I could be in it for you.
I know you do,
but that's because you're
on Xanax and I'm, I'm,
I wouldn't even fight back cause
I'm on pot. I love you buddy.
Love you Joe. Thanks for him.
If you're around next Wednesday,
we're doing an ice house show, um, in,
uh, Knoxville, Knoxville, Tennessee,
boom. Anything you ever want me to
tweet, brother? You know, it just,
I appreciate my way. My friends love
you. The comedy people love you.
The the people that get ahold of me on
Twitter, there are huge fans of Dama rare.
And one of the things that they love most
about the podcast is being introduced
to all these great comedians. You know,
it's true. Your Aria, you or so it's a,
it helps everybody. So more than happy
to do it. My brother. Thanks Joe.
I'll talk to dom. I rare on
Twitter, the two R's. I double r.
E. R. H. This dom, I
rare with one. Are you?
Fuck you fucking fraud.
How they must be a WHO's Listerine marine
if there isn't a fake diamond or are
they already put it together?
Thanks to Squarespace,
go to squarespace.com entering the code
Joe and the number one that's jus and
the number one just so you have
your old friend off some money.
And if you want to enter into the podcast
sponsorship slash Squarespace contest,
we will pick four winners that have
designed the most beautiful website in
Squarespace.
We'll give these winners a free year of
Squarespace and we'll send these winters
a swag bag with items like
an apple keyboard, a tee
shirt, a MOLST getting more.
You know what? Fuck it. I'm
going to throw it in a higher,
a higher prime eight t shirt.
How about that? How about that?
You get a free higher primate tee shirt.
I didn't have a lot of that is in Texas,
man. I'm just doing that because I'm
nice. Okay. I just made it up on the spot.
Tweet those ideas by this January the
17th to Hashtag j r e Squarespace and uh,
the higher primary tee shirt, you'll be
able to choose whichever one you want.
I just made it up right there.
I like that.
That's how I roll dot Merera when
I'm with you, I get inspired. I,
I've been seeing you role. I run
with things a Tim, thank you.
Also to Ting for sponsoring our podcast.
Uh,
hugely happy with this as a sponsor
and nothing but positive results.
rogan.ting.com go there and save $25
off your first ting device when you sign
up. You fucking freaks. We're also
brought to you by on it. That's o. N, n.
I. T. Use the code name, Rogan,
and save 10% off any and all
supplements. Much love you, dirty Fox,
and we will see you in about 15
minutes with Brian dunning. Big Kiss.
Okay.